e
e e
called to order the meeting for February
11th of the children and family law
committee and uh representative Greg
could you tell us in a two or three
sentences about the unfortunate thing
that took place last week sure well um
as most of the committee knows at this
point but representative uh Grossman's
one of her twin boys Oscar actually had
a very traumatic fall and is in critical
condition um down at Mass General so
thank you and uh I have been asked if we
could spend a brief minute
in prayer for Oscar and vice chair D
Simon would you lead us in that
please thank you Mr chair for those of
you who do pray please join with us
uh dear
God please put your healing
hands on Oscar and his family during
their terrible
time please give them strength and send
them your love and our love and know
that our thoughts and prayers are with
them as well in Jesus name I pray amen
amen I open the hearing on House Bill
4:30 reducing the retention period for
records of unfounded abuse and neglect
reports by DHHS Prime sponsor uh
chairman James Spain come on
up thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I introduced this bill
uh because I believe 10 years of
retention for an unfounded report is
exessive if you read through this bill
you'll see that a screened out report is
already kept for four
years if at some point that screened out
report is deemed
unfounded it's kept for an additional 10
years from the date that the report was
deemed
unfounded this does not deal with
reports that were deemed founded
or unfounded but with reasonable concern
those are kept
indefinitely this is dealing only with
unfounded
reports and having a report kept for 10
years hanging over the heads of a family
like the sort of
Damocles is an
unreasonable mental anguish for that
family especially where if at any time
during that 10 years another false
report is made against the family and
it's deemed unfounded again the clock
starts at 10 years for all previous
reports that were deemed
unfounded so you could have a
multiplying effect of report after
report after report 10 years starting
all over again and they won't go away
and by the time they do go away that
child is more than 50 % chance is now a
grown adult and the family still has
this hanging over their
head I can bring an
example from several years ago when I
was speaking with one of the members of
the police training
facility and he'd been through a divorce
and had custody of his children and uh
50% and
uh oddly enough every time that there
was some major event that they were
going to be celebrating together with it
be a trip to Disney World or whether it
be the sweet 16 birthday of the daughter
or uh some other family gathering where
he was taking the children
somewhere a few weeks before that was to
happen a report would be
made with
DCF and it was his belief that his
ex-wife was behind it just to sort of
spoil his time with the children but
each time that happened of course he had
an unfounded report that would then
start over
again
and these don't go away
quickly I believe that three years is
much more
reasonable three years gives the chance
that it can go away before another
report is falsely made against a
family I believe that in as much as we
as legislators are supposed to protect
children from from the abuse of
strangers and bad parents we also need
to protect those families and those
children from abuse by the
state and holding these kinds of things
over the head of a family is mental
abuse it
constitutes something that is always
there always hanging over them and it's
like a a Paul cast upon the family for
the entire time until it goes
away this would not stop the clock
restarting with another abuse case filed
but it would be for three years not
and we some of us may disagree whether
three is better than 10 I think we can
all hopefully agree that 10 is excessive
it's almost the entire lifespan of the
child until they turn
18 I would inform the committee that I
don't have a problem if we come up with
a number in between three and 10 if
that's something the committee wants to
entertain but I believe we have to make
progress in trying to
alleviate
the uh burden of having this something
that the state holds over the heads when
it's an unfounded report
to have it have it there on an innocent
family where it can be constantly
referenced by people as you know well
they've got a report on them sitting
with
dcyf and again I'll reiterate a founded
report is kept
indefinitely and one that's as as if you
look at
line 10 you'll see uh founded unfounded
but with reasonable concern is also kept
indefinitely so if there's any concern
and they report is unfounded but with
reasonable concern this doesn't apply
but if it's totally
unfounded there's no reason to keep that
report hanging over the family for 10
years and with that I'll take any
questions your most recent comment uh
goes to a question I had written down
that unfounded does not mean there's no
problem it's just is's not enough proof
it's the difference between being
innocent and not guilty um but you what
you just said seemed to answer my
question in line 10 an unfounded report
but there is reasonable
concern um does keep the report on file
is that correct assumption indefinitely
okay thank you representative Greg thank
you so just to clarify you are aware
that
unfounded um in unfounded without
anything else does not mean that there
was nothing found it also does not mean
a false report correct I do know that
okay follow up and are you also aware
that and maybe the people that are
concerned about this this is not like a
a sex offenders list or anything where
people can look this up it's incredibly
hard to obtain and look to see if there
is some kind of a um report even
unfounded on somebody this is not
something that there is a register of
that anybody can see an employer family
member anything else are you aware of
that I'm aware of that however it also
is in the minds of the people in that
family constantly until it goes away
it's as though they have to live with
this ghost hanging over
them until it's
gone representative rice thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so would you not agree that by
keeping these unfounded reports for the
length of time we did could also be
helpful if you are finding malicious
reporting you would have a record of all
of these unfounded reports to help prove
malicious reporting and I believe that
could be done uh yes thank you for your
question uh I believe that could be done
in 3 years I believe that any follow-up
investigation that isn't completed in 3
years is probably not going to happen
but having it sit there for 10 is
excessive
thank you for your testimony thank you
chair recognizes Cassandra Sanchez and
attorney Lisa masio from the office of
the child
advocate armed with handouts as always
yes together uh need to grab a CH
good morning and thank you for allowing
me to speak today my name for the record
is Cassandra Sanchez I the child
advocate for the State of New
Hampshire um as you will see we are
passing around some written testimony um
and we are here today in opposition to
House Bill
430 um a number of reasons for this um
one of them being it directly impacts
the day-to-day work of the office of the
child advocate in part of our work we're
looking at Trends in the system things
that are working well areas of
improvement and to be able to do so
having history of families um the any
touch points they've had with the agency
any actions by the agency in that time
frame allows us to see if the agency is
growing in the right direction um in
addition to that we also see over time
in many um cases that we review
particularly um in a lot of the critical
incidents that we review and which
critical incidents are serious injuries
to Children um it can be a child
fatality it can also include parent
fatalities uh we review all of those in
our office and in doing so an aspect of
that is looking at all of the history of
those families um unless it is a newborn
baby we always see that there has been
prior history at the point of going to a
critical incident if it's a firstborn
child often times there may not be a
history but when we actually have gone
back and looked at our CS every every
single cir has at least one call in to
the agency before it's risen to the
point that something serious has
happened to that child or to that family
unit um we also look at this as calls
are coming in and if we receive calls of
concern to our office that somebody is
worried about a child the first thing
that we do is go in directly into the
dcyf case management system and see what
touch points that family has had with
the agency um in that we have found
times where it has taken multiple
reports over lengthy periods of time to
truly build the full picture of what
that child is experiencing so it may be
you know the first call from a school
Personnel saying the child's falling
asleep in school something seems off
then it may be a call from a neighbor
we're hearing a lot of yelling in the
home something is happening and it
actually takes a totality of all of
those calls to build the full picture to
say this is rising to the level of abuse
or neglect the first few calls very well
could be screened out but with those
screened screen outs living in the
system the agency is able to look back
and paint a picture of what is this
child truly going through and do we need
to intervene to support this family and
ensure the safety of that particular
child I also do want to thank
representative rice for her comment um
because we have seen it work in that
aspect as well we have seen where you
can go back into records and see that
there may be a history of malicious
calls um typically when we review those
kinds of cases it does have to do with
um a nasty divorce and one parent may be
calling repeatedly against the other
parent and by having that in the system
it is protective to that one parent who
is doing right by their child and it
builds that history so when the next
call comes in they can see those priors
and say this sounds like what's been
called in time and time again and we
know it's not abuse or neglect we know
this is you know clearly there's
something playing out here in the
Dynamics in this family um and it's not
appropriate for the agency to be
involved so it does work um we see it
working both ways but there is a lot
that we can gain from that history and
having that historical information um
not only benefits the work that we do in
trying to improve the overall system but
it does improve the day-to-day work of
social workers within DCF and it is
actually um within their own policies
that they are to um review the the
history when they have a new call come
in about a family so they're really
assessing that the full picture of the
family with any information that they've
ever received on
them uh we also attached some data there
for you um on the final page um and so
this is some data that we pulled um
reports made to intake during um January
2025 so those first few bullet points
there are specific to this past month um
and
the typically because of the time frame
we don't have um founded unfounded or or
incomplete results of an investigation
30 days later so we pulled
2024 data to take a look at um the
founded unfounded and incomplete and as
you will see um what they have here and
these are for all calls received to the
division in that time frame um
78% for whether it be founded unfounded
or incomplete so all calls in 2024 that
came in 78% had previous referrals at
some point um and if you look at the
data there we also include um percentage
of reports with referrals that were more
than 3 years um since and so we have all
of that data there for you to um look
into a bit more but wanted to share that
it is very relevant that do come back to
the
system and I just wanted to reiterate
from a a legal standpoint uh
representative Greg's Point um the
central registry which only contains
founded reports is itself incredibly
difficult to access under New Hampshire
law very few entities even get access to
that it is certainly not public record
and in fact um people you may think
would have access to central registry do
not the founded in screen notes which
are live entirely within dcf's internal
database is accessible to essentially no
one outside of DCF the office of child
advocate has access specifically through
our statute under a very strict
confidentiality mou and those records
are protected by 170 g8a they are not
accessible by a 91a record request and
170 GAA is extremely narrowly tailored
to only allow access to a very small
group of folks including parents who are
the subject of those reports but
otherwise it is not as though these
records are publicly accessible public
knowledge um so the confidentiality
around these records regardless of how
long they're retained are incredibly
High representative rice thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question do you happen to know what the
averages for other states I did we just
put this in like in
2017 or something right because that was
best practices for other states yes that
is that is accurate I don't have the
average for other states but um I can
say for neighboring states that we end
up working with on a regular basis they
do maintain their records for quite some
time you know if we have a family that's
come here from another state the state
of New Hampshire will request those
records and they can get a a very ly um
time frame of records from those States
as well and so some of them have a a
lifetime where they they keep them
forever for the the history of their
agency um and others do have that the
longer time frame that we we um strove
here in New Hampshire to raise in it was
about 2017 yes that's correct thank you
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you would you believe
that New York keeps theirs for 10 years
past the youngest child in the family's
18th birthday in Massachusetts keeps the
indefinitely yes I can absolutely say
for my work in Massachusetts they do
keep them indefinitely there yes um and
and yes that time frame for New York
would be accurate as well yes thank you
representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question would you agree
that there are times in um in the case
of a family with multiple children that
the oldest child um might have there
might be reports about the oldest child
that might be unfounded but with younger
children subsequent reports might show a
a more I'm struggling to find the word
but more intensity of abuse to that
would rise to the occasion of um having
some action taken and then when you look
back you might need to uh provide help
and services for the older child as well
yes absolutely um so there there are
many cases that we review in our office
where um an older child may even be
freed for adoption um and adopted out of
the system because of severity of
parenting at that time and then later
down the line parents have other
children um and if they do become reinol
it's it is often looking for their
Trends in Behavior because what that
tells us those calls are telling us the
behavior of that parent um and their
parenting style and there are plenty of
times where a child could be adopted out
and the family could really learn from
that and and take services and grow and
have an opportunity to parent
successfully in the future it is not an
automatic because you had a termination
of your rights on another child that the
system is is following you or is is
tracking if you're going to have other
children that does not happen um but
there are other times where we see then
those same behaviors that had happened
in a case that could have been 10 plus
years ago it those behaviors are
resurfacing with a new child born and so
that tells us that that parent hasn't
had an opportunity to learn and grow
their behavior in a more POs to to um
create more positive parenting in the
future and that history of what happened
with that older child is very important
to understand what may play out with
that new child and to be able to prevent
something serious from happening um and
allow intervention earlier on by the
agency any other questions for our
friends from OCA no seeing none thank
you so much thank
you chair
recognizes attorney Susan larabe
from DCF who
has
information good morning Susan laraby
general counsel for DCF and I'm going to
have in my my brain the brevity and
concise and clear uh recommendation that
you mentioned before and listening to
the OCA as well as listening to
everyone's questions here I really do
not have much much to add except for I
think as written there may be some um
inconsistencies of now with the
retention
because as it's written now the
retention of a screenout and again just
to define a screen out is when a case is
called into Central intake and it does
not meet a definition of abuse and
neglect so it is never even referred in
for an assessment is what's called
screened out and the way the bill is
written that remains untouched so that
would be retained for 4
years however an unfounded report
would be now retained for 3 years so an
unfounded report in which it was
screened in for an assessment there was
enough evidence at that point to screen
it in it did meet one the definition
taking at face meet one the definitions
for abuse and neglect would be kept for
a shorter period of time than a screened
out case and representative rice you are
correct as well as representative Nelson
there were many changes that have been
made to the retention uh statute through
out many years of working on this as
well as one of the latest changes in
2017 also added another component of how
an unfounded report could be used under
the definition section I'm sorry the
evidence section of 169
C12 uh the evidence section it says that
in any hearing under this chapter the
court shall not be bound by the
technical Rules of Evidence and may
admit evidence which it considers
relevant and material and then added in
2017 evidence of Prior unfounded or
unfounded reports of abuse and neglect
shall be admissible in proceedings under
this chapter in order to establish a
relevant pattern or course of
conduct so we just want to be clear that
that unfounded is used in many different
areas of the 169c including 169 C12 as I
just mentioned as well as 169
c34 which lays out the different duties
of the Department of Health and Human
Services DCF in particular when we are
investigating and assessing uh cases of
abuse and neglect specifically
section uh B which states determine
whether any person in the same family or
household was named in a prior report of
abuse or neglect and if there are two or
more prior unfounded or unfounded but
with reasonable concern reports
involving any family or household member
conduct an administrative review of all
identified reports because as many of
you mentioned on this panel is essential
to make sure internally that we have not
missed something that there is is there
a reason why there has been two
unfounded reports on this family and
this statute
requires us to do
that I'm happy to take any other
questions do you find it very difficult
at DCF to have a whole group of people
very angry at you because uh you didn't
take a child from a bad home and another
group equally angry that you did and is
that difficult of course it's difficult
but of course we're here to follow the
law and first and foremost make sure
every child that we are touching upon is
is safe and evaluate that safety and
that risk and make sure again at the end
of the day we have not missed something
inside that
family
representative sorry thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for asking my for
answering my question um I am very new
to child and family this is my first
year um but I did notice in the bill it
refers to a report that is unfounded but
with reasonable concern
I'm wondering how many cases if you have
any statistics on how many cases are
found are labeled as unfounded but with
reasonable concern I do not have that
data in front of me I know we do track
that data and I could provide that for
you and I will I do believe that was
that uh category unfounded with
reasonable concerns was one of the
latest changes that have have been made
to the statute um I okay
and basically what that means is that
there is still insufficient evidence to
sustain a pro a preponderance of the
evidence finding however there is
reasonable concerns there's probable
cause so it's at that very beginning
stage representative cousen for the
followup um do parents know uh the
difference between an unfounded and a
unfounded with reasonable concern and I
only asked that because I've never heard
a parents say well it was unfounded with
reasonable concern it's always they drop
it at
unfounded yes when this the case is
actually closed they are given not just
verbal uh they're given verbal U
conversations with their case worker the
assistant worker they're also giving a
form a formal letter which identifies
that that category has been made lets
them know that they have not been added
to the central registry that there's
still no finding against them however
defines what that concern is what is
that reasonable
concern any further
questions thank you counselor
appreciate and this concludes the
hearing on House Bill 4:30 we will not
be executing this until early March so
therefore if people wish to amend it
tweak it do whatever with with it look
up some things you've got a couple weeks
I open the hearing on House Bill 187
relative to restraining orders sought by
a parent on behalf of a minor child
representative belshire Prime sponsor
welcome good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee happy to be with you
this morning to introduce this bill that
I hope will represent just a bit of
housekeeping and a simple fix to a
problem that has come
up
so for the record representative Mike
beler Caroll District 4
Wakefield first as you members of this
committee I'm sure are very well aware
children are in a bit of a unique
position because many of their rights
and privileges as Citizens are held in
trust by their parents or Guardians for
them until they reach the age of
majority
this acknowledges the basic fact that
children are not independent rather
children are quite
dependent unfortunately it appears that
we have crafted law I believe probably
in error as the result of the evolution
of laws over
time that deprives children of certain
legal remedies that are otherwise
available to
adults I believe this circumstance it
presently exists is actually in
violation of the United States
Constitution amendment 14 clause for
equal protection we're simply not
allowed to craft law that treats people
differently under different under the
same
circumstances presently there are a
variety of options legal options for
adults to seek restraining orders that
extend past the borders of their own
household to other members of
Society it does appear that we en we
lack the enabling legislation that
allows children to exercise that same
privilege of law through their parents
by bringing restraining orders on their
behalf um now to address a different a
little bit of a different issue perhaps
there is some skepticism I don't know
about this committee but I have a little
bit of skepticism myself if I'm honest
about some of the due process Provisions
that exist
in restraining orders generally however
let me be clear that any consternation
about that should not be a reason to
oppose this legislation because that's
not the principle at play here the
principle at play here is that something
available to adults generally should not
be prohibited from children under law a
legal remedy now there are some specific
circumstances that led to me bringing
this bill a constituent of mine brought
forward I'm not going to go into detail
on that I'm sure some other people will
speak to the um rather horrific
circumstances that this unfortunate
error has led to in New Hampshire
law but the bottom line is this the
principle here at play is impartiality
and equal protection and we should not
make any remedy available to an adult an
adult that isn't also available for a
child with an adult their Guardian
acting on their behalf and with that I'm
happy to take question
questions representative
Raymond uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question uh my
question so my question is about where
this bill is aimed to go in statute
because it is being put into RSA 169c
which is the child abuse and neglect
statute and the rest the entire rest of
that statute is only people who are
legally responsible for the care of the
child who can be charged with abuse and
neglect whereas my understanding of this
this particular bill it's to be aimed at
somebody who is not a member of that
child's household who has no legal
Authority and thus would not otherwise
be covered by the statute so my question
is why would the bill not focus on a on
a civil restraining order which would
cover like an adult to an adult or any
other person why not make a carve out
under the Civil restraining order
protection that allows an adult to seek
civil restraining order for a child
thank you for the question so frankly
our laws where it comes to restraining
orders generally exist as a bit of a
patchwork it is frankly Beyond me to and
my capability and expertise to try to
recraft the whole of restraining order
law to no longer be a patchwork I'm
trying to work within the existing
framework and it is this law that
enables parents to bring this civil
complaint for restraining order on
behalf of their child so it was it was
just a simple matter of this is where it
already was this is where the error I
believe exists in language that only
extends it to a Minor's family or
household so this was the logical place
to work for the time being at least
until such a time comes that somebody
far more expert than I am can sort out
the broader Patchwork of issues that
might exist in law
presentative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question and you and I
have spoken and we have both spoken to
the same family and thank you for so
eloquently presenting the bill and um
and the problem would you agree that
right now without
this becoming law there are children in
New Hampshire who are in Danger from
people who they should be kept away
from yes and thank you for the question
and and as I said without getting too
deeply into the broader questions about
restraining orders in general we have a
system in place that allows adults to
reek restraining orders for a variety of
reasons including members outside their
own household and we as a body have
affirmed those laws meaning that we as a
body seem to think that there are adults
in danger who should be protected but
yes unfortunately due to some I believe
some errors that
happened as the laws evolved children
were left out of this and are therefore
continuing to be in the kind of danger
that we've protected adults from and we
should therefore extend that protection
to
Children any other questions of the
representative seeing none thank you for
your testimony thank you and the chair
recognizes I think it's Alanda Peterson
can you hear me now um my name is Landa
Peterson I actually created Jade's law
in
2019 and um sorry it's very emotional
for me um I was contacted by Bikers
Against Child Abuse that they were
helping another family and was made Ware
that the wording in the law only States
for family and I just wanted to come
down here today to say that that was
never my
intention um when I spoke about it
before in testimony I I said um Soccer
Coaches pastors it didn't matter who the
person was I believe that all the
children should have the same rights and
protections as everybody else um
I am currently using Jade's law because
our Predator was family um and I'm glad
we made it um I'm happy that another
family has the opportunity to speak on
it and hopefully change the
wording
um I just want to help all the families
and all the kids and um help them feel
protected and safe
would you be open to taking any
questions sure any
questions representative
rice thank you Mr chairman it's not
really a question but I do remember you
from when this bill came through and the
Bikers Against Child Abuse and so thank
you for even bringing this to our
attention in the first place and let's
see if we can expand on it you're
welcome I thank you um it's actually
another mom that brought this wording um
today that she's going to speak um but I
also wanted to say that um I had written
a book on Kindle and Amazon about our
whole case if you want to learn more
about what we went through as a family
and the fact that my child had autism
and
spoke and her own representation in
court and we talk about the
bikers and um it's very good book to
educate
yourselves what's that representative
Nelson What's the title of that thank
you my name means ready for battle CU
that's what Alanda actually means it's
okay thank you thank you Mr chairman for
the question for thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my
question thank you and everyone else
thank
you and committee I forgot we're
supposed to have that sign changed on
the witness table for every new
bill representative
Malone you are not only very skilled but
you're
nearest you have to take out the other I
know I know I know I
know you know that's a hard thing to do
when there's about 40 people watching
you
well done well done awesome yay chair
recognizes Tracy
Sirles is this s yes okay it
is um good morning my name is Tracy
Sirles and I'm here here today in hopes
of resolving a serious issue that my
family has run into this past summer I
discovered that one of my children was a
victim of sexual abuse at the hands of
their best friend's
father when the state police got
involved in the case they instructed me
to go to the courthouse and file for a
restraining order on behalf of my child
I did what I was instructed to do sadly
the judge had to deny the protection
orders that I requested on behalf of my
child the reason my request was denied
is because the child protection act RSA
c7a currently states that a parent or
Guardian May file a petition for
protection order on behalf of a minor
alleging abuse of the Minor by a member
of the members Minor's family or
household my child was sexually abused
by an individual who is not a family
member and not a member of our
household I was shocked when I was
informed that the clerk by the clerk
that my only option was to get the
restraining to get the restraining
orders to go home get my child bring
them in and have them file for their own
restraining
order the way the law currently stands a
minor must file for a restraining order
for themselves no matter their age or
intellectual abilities I believe this is
an oversight in the law the age of
majority in New Hampshire is 18 years
old anyone under 18 is considered a
minor a minor in definition is anyone
who is under the age of full legal
responsibility or person who is not yet
old enough to have the rights of an
adult a young child cannot understand
the full ramifications of a restraining
order let alone understand how to file
one honestly I myself needed assistance
from starting point to fill out the
petition for the protection order
because it was so
confusing how is it that this law
requires minor children to file legal
documentation on their own when the
definition of minor clearly states under
the age of full legal responsibility and
not old enough to have the rights of an
adult I am legally responsible for my
children's safety education shelter food
clothing if I were to ignore any of
those responsibilities I would be at
risk of losing my my children for
neglect or
abuse how is it possible that I
responsible for my children's
safety yet there's a law that
specifically is precluding me from being
able to protect my
child the abuse that my child suffered
at the hands of someone who was outside
of my household and not a family member
holds no less I'm
sorry holds no less
significance I should be offered the
same rights of protection over my
children as those stated in child
protection act RSA 169
c7a please help me in fixing this over
say thank you for your
time would you take questions if there's
any I can try well I'm completely out of
my element but I'm willing to do
whatever it takes well I want to confess
to you we are too sometimes so anyway
any
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your story it's very
comping J recognizes
Joseph B R
O give me the last part of your last
name please Brown oh oh come on
yeah that one was
tough thank you um I'll be brief um I
believe as has been said
sorry um as have been said this you know
New Hampshire has a mish mash of how the
restraining orders work and I'm pretty
sure when Jade's law was put in place
initially this was done with model
legislation from other jurisdictions and
as often is the case when that happens
things don't quite mesh with our laws
and it ends up with an unintended result
and I don't believe the legislature ever
intended to
exclude a whole class of Potential
abusers from the option to get a
restraining order so I believe this is a
very simple solution to fix that and yes
as said it you know it ends up in a
weird act but you know in a weird
portion in the rsas but it's the way
that the rsas are currently written it's
really the only way to do it without
completely revamping that
currently a parent could get a civil
restraining order through the superior
court system right and solve this at
Great expense rather than going to the
circuit court system so this this puts
it in the same system that is currently
used for restraining orders rather than
having to go for a general restraining
order at Great expense which would limit
the option to only a few members of
society who can afford to hire a legal
team to
obtain a restraining order to protect
their child this is the much simpler
solution to
that I don't think I have much to add
it's I think it's a pretty simple
solution it solves the problem without
undo
effort Mr Brown would you take questions
absolutely any questions from Mr Brown
seeing none thank you thank you that's
the sum of the pink cards I have uh
unless who turn is it to clog the works
up over
here is it your turn it is my turn are
you clogging up a pink card I I'm not I
I just wanted to make a quick statement
on the Bell uh uh Mr chairman committee
members and audience members I am
noticing Two Gentlemen uh in the
audience who I believe have worked
Wonders on behalf of children who have
been intimidated hurt and abused by
people I personally was here when you
some of you
spoke before and I just want to thank
you for protecting our state's
children thank you thank you oh come on
go
ahead that's nice sing further cards I
close the hearing on House Bill
187 and with the approval of the ranking
member um I open an executive session on
187 so we can vote on this right now and
send it on its way now whoever
moves
OTP gets to write the would you like to
do this
I would if that's okay you would like to
do this yes all right in full
disclosure I bought Girl Scout cookies
from somebody else yesterday I did that
that is okay my girls have aged out
already so you're good they have hit
Middle School age and they have decided
not to continue which is okay with me as
long as you support um the community as
a whole for Girl Scouts that's I'm a
sucker for a s star you know that you
know there are a lot of girls out there
who have benefited from Girl Scouts and
I am glad to see that support in any way
possible representative would you think
it appropriate that the people who are
listening to our dialogue might
feel compelled to buy some cookies from
their Girl Scouts that they
know hopefully yes and
hopefully encourage those to join as
well too represent ative Le levac for a
motion I move ought to
pass okay a republican second because we
do this representative
rice we don't get
thirds any
discussion representative
love thank you Mr chair thanks for uh
taking my comments here uh my my only
problem is uh the effective date I think
it should read immediately after
signing that would take an
amendment yeah let's get it let's get it
across the way yeah but thank
you any other comments representative
Raymond um thank you Mr chairman I think
that there is clearly a gap in the law
that was unintended um that is when I
heard about this case I was I mean you
could have knocked me over with a
feather I was flabbergasted that you
couldn't get a restraining order for
your child um having said that I don't
think that the child protection statute
is the place to do it because Child
Protection statute is designed for
people who have a caregiving
responsibility so that after a finding
they can receive rehabilitative services
and reestablish a relationship with that
child with the exception of of sexual
abuse um so I just don't think it's the
right place for it I'm going to vote for
for it because I think we need to Gap it
but I would really feel more comfortable
if there was a bill or if this bill were
amended when it goes along the other
side to put the change in language under
the other restraining order statutes so
that in those circumstances where it is
a coach or a neighbor down the road or
whomever the parent could file for the
minor instead of in 173b where it says
now a minor can file for themselves
because I feel like that would more
address the circumstances that we're
talking about in the way that um the the
relief is being sought if this bill
passes all the way through and is signed
into law we can bring back something on
this subject next year the prohibition
is only if it's to the negative and I
really don't anticipate that so um I bet
you could find somebody who would do
just that to not make new law but put
them where they belong okay anybody
else motion before us is OTP ought to
pass move by representative LC and
seconded by representative
rice House Bill 187 would one of MC
Clerk's call the
rooll chairman Pearson yes
representative D Simon yes
representative rice yes representative
McMahon yes yeah representative Nelson
yes representative sidel yes
representative love yes representative
coren yes representative marel is not
here representative Petrino yes
representative lavesque yes
representative Greg yes representative
Raymond yes representative georgees yes
and representative Maloney
yes 14 to
nothing it passes 14 to0 representative
is that an Irish Malone or an Italian
Maloney I I knew that but that's
just this concludes the exec session on
House Bill
187 and uh we have 10 minutes before we
take up the next
bill I don't think it can it can be
because it's got money on on
it thank
you thank
you God's
listening thank
you thanks what you doing
e
e e
representative litfield please present
your bill thank you Mr chair I would
like to please ask permission to bring
Melissa blasic up with me when I
introduce the bill would that be okay
you may do
so she gets legislative alumna points
The Honorable Melissa Blas excuse me I'm
sorry about that so I'm here to
introduce House Bill 560 uh I am
representative Melissa Lichfield
representing the towns of Brentwood
Danville and Fremont uh this bill is not
new to the state legislature legisl it
has been brought up two times prior
actually um and the reason why I've
brought up Melissa is because she's got
a whole lot of history on this I've
served here in the state house um this
is my second term non-consecutive and
when I was not in I was actually getting
calls from parents that were very
concerned about this they were unable to
access their children's medical records
electronically once they hit the age of
13 um they were told that the child had
to set up their own email uh they
couldn't act they couldn't even set up
appointments for their children so it's
it's morphed into um to quite a lot I've
talked to quite a lot of people um not
only is the feeling that they should
have access simply because the parents
are the caregivers who knows best how to
take care of their children but also um
you have the medical bills that are
involved as
well and I'm yeah I'm anyone name
Melissa at the table may speak yeah and
I'm just I'm going to say full I hate to
say this I always just keep it real but
I'm Type A and I'm I've got I have a dog
that just died at home and a sick kid so
here I am and this is why she's she's
here to be my quarterback today so thank
you thank you Mr chair um so I'm Melissa
blasic I'm here representing rebuild NH
uh yes as a somebody who does advocate
for parental rights this is probably the
mo most ubiquitous complaint I get from
parents typically when they push back
it's let's say a doctor's office about
this they're always told this is oh it's
required by law so I think that they of
often think that in state law there's
something that says that a child loses
loses access to a portal system at age
12 which is not true but it is true that
the laws have made it tricky for portal
systems now to be clear all parents have
rights to their child's physical paper
medical record and any parent parent who
goes and requests their child's physical
Pap paper medical record will receive it
but they will receive it hand redacted
for certain items okay so federal
law um title 10 I believe requires that
children over the age of 12 have access
to birth control treatments and
addiction services without parental
consent so those would be things that
could be would need to be redacted from
medical record
and state law um kind of redundantly um
requires access to Addiction Services
and also STD uh testing and treatment so
those would also be things that needed
to be redacted when we put this bill in
I believe it was actually in 2023 and
then we retained it to
2024 and then
ultimately it was ited because there was
word coming down from the federal
government that they were going to be
handling this and that never happened so
we're back that's why this bill is in
again
um
the issues with the portal system
supposedly is that it doesn't redact in
the same way that a paper document can
be redacted and so I think what sort of
happened is that medical provid writers
have just felt like this is the simplest
solution is to just cut off
access um but I mean I don't know about
your 12-year-old but um most 12year olds
are really not capable you can see i' I
I've passed around um a couple examples
of hos of policies from different
doctor's offices some even specify that
the child cannot um use the parents
email address so now your child has to
have their own email address now of
course
listen most parents are going to set up
an email address for their child that
they have full access to you would think
um to do it that way but this is just
something that parents come to me all
the time and they're just outraged that
they even have to jump through these
hoops to be able to have full parental
access to their child's medical records
most people are not seeing paper we all
have the portals that's how they keep
track of things so um that is the
purpose of this bill that's sort of the
history of this bill and why we are back
today I'll take any questions thank you
very much uh as a preface a brief
preface to my question uh I am part-time
a medical center
CEO and uh one of our providers is my
wife who's a family practice physician
and very often we discover that Hippa
those sacred five letters are invoked
when Hippa doesn't say what it's being
invoked to it is a brush off in some
cases and therefore would you believe
that sometimes people already have more
rights but maybe we better put more into
statute I would absolutely believe that
boy that was a push question wow okay
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman um I have two things one I did
not get your hand out I don't know where
it I just have one copy of some policies
floating around that I I have
highlighted out the children's policies
and then there's another handout that uh
representative Lichfield put out of the
things that are sort of required in
different statutes there are copies of
that okay so if maybe it could be
emailed to the committee I would love to
see
it there there are copies no I have that
one I don't have the other one oh the
other one the co the copies of the
policies yeah I I have one copy of
several policies floating around
representative Malone since you are
caring for the sign it is not necessary
for you to take on other difficulties
thank you so much thank you Mr chair
representative Greg can I ask my
question though you may ask your
question thank you Mr I did see your
hand okay thank you my question is
regarding line 19 line 19 of your bill
uh says when a healthc care provider has
determined by and I'm going to use air
quotes here clear and convincing
evidence based upon articulated facts
blah blah etc etc um then they can
withhold the record yeah my question is
where did that language come from from
because RSA 169c and every Child
Protection Law in every state of the
country says that the duty of the
practitioner is if they have reasonable
cause to suspect and every state in the
country says for a finding of abuse and
neglect so for a court to determine a
parent is abusive it's a preponderance
of the evidence so where did this clear
and convincing random level come from
and thank you for the question I did not
write this this is a word for word the
bill that was put in before I personally
object to this particular part and I
would like that section to be stricken
if I'm just that would be my personal
preference um I think that if a medical
professional does have any type of
thought that the child is um possibly
being abused or neglected they are
mandatory reporters and um they
that that's how this happens medic they
are not judges and juries to be able to
remove people's parental
rights so there there is an amendment in
the works but I just wanted to let you
know the reason why the bill is wed the
way that it is is because they've tried
to put this
bill through two times prior and they
were concerns about if they didn't have
this language was the bill going to make
it past the Finish Line it's just as
simple as that but you're 100%
absolutely right it is not necessary and
there is an amendment out
there thank you because I that's what
killed it the last two times it was here
it's that
phrase representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and presenting the bill and taking my
question so I are there cases where
parents are not able so you're talking
about the online like the chart and
stuff I have a daughter that just turned
18 it was until she turned 18 that she
had to sign like a a release or whatever
if she wanted me to be able to continue
to do it that's when my email got shut
down same uh with my son who's now 21 it
wasn't until he turned 18 that I was no
longer able to access it with what I had
before so is that actually
happening uh thank you for the question
yeah I mean when I was researching I
couldn't find a major practice that did
not have a policy that you lost portal
access at 12 um I I stopped printing
them off cuz they were all the same um
and and so yeah no I and I haven't
that's interesting that you say that CU
I I haven't found that to be the case I
mean my daughter is at a very small
practice that's not associated with any
major hospital and that's their policy
as well um so
yeah followup or second question it's a
second question um so it's a
it's a would you believe I suppose so I
I make no secret that I'm a Survivor of
domestic violence and as well as my
children are would you believe that one
of the first things um that my late
husband did when he was taken out of the
home was to try to access their medical
records before we had findings before we
had protection orders or anything else
um to see if they were talking about
something that he'd
done sure I would believe that I I
believe that's why section B is in here
but I I would like to point out that
this bill is specifically directed
toward electronic records so in that
case unfortunately if he were to go in
person he would have access to their
records um I read in line 8 physical
medical records and yes electronic
medical records yes it's both so it is
both it is it is both yes but currently
they would be we just put it in there to
keep it clean but currently they can
have access that that's federal law do
you want to follow up okay any else
question for the representative and the
representative once
removed thank you Melissa thank you
thank you anybody else named Melissa who
wishes to testify seeing none
representative Mary Murphy
thank you Mr chairman esteemed
colleagues members of the public I am
Mary Murphy representing Hillsboro
District 27 which is Dearing in
francistown I'm also the CEO of a
healthc care startup cost cures which I
co-founded with an emergency medicine
physician I'm here to testify in support
of HB
560 relative to parental access to minor
and child's medical records I feel this
bill is needed to ensure that minor
Children's Health Care is properly
coordinated by providing essential
access to minor Children's Medical
Records by parents except in certain
circumstances when it is not in the best
interest of the child the bill clearly
spells out these exceptions which I will
not repeat for the sake of
brevity one of the problems the bill
seeks to address is a situation in which
a minor child receives medication or
care without the knowledge of his or her
parent and is then treated with
contraindicated medication or a
procedure that could lead uh or could
result in a life-threatening reaction or
even death this bill would help avoid
these situations I view HB 560 as
life-saving legislation and urge you to
vote ought to pass thank you are there
any questions repres representative
Murphy wonders if there's any questions
representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um that that
actually has been a concern of mine um
also with the portal system and I
further to what you were saying uh would
you say that also medications that are
necessary for whatever Health reason um
when they are prescribed to a child and
the practice of the practice is to
request refills via the portal and
leaving that responsibility to the minor
child could that be harmful for the
child if they are not responsible in
obtaining uh refills on time I believe
it
could any other questions for
representative Murphy seeing none thank
you I appreciate it thank you very much
and the chair recognizes representative
McFarland he says he's from Orange I
think he's from south of London just
wait thank
you Scottish Origins not
English morning Mr chairman honorable
members I'm representative Donald
mcfallen from Orange and I thank you for
the opportunity to speak in strong
support of House Bill 560 this testimony
is uh representing My Views and the
views and interests of of my
constituents in Grafton 18 my testimony
is not made on behalf of any private
employer uh nor should it be construed
to reflect the views of any of my
employers uh it's absurd and outrageous
that parents who are legally and morally
responsible for their children are
unable to obtain electronic medical
records or are being handed redacted
electronic medical records when they are
seeking essential information about
their children's health it's even more
absurd and outrageous to learn as we
have done earlier in this testimony that
healthc care providers are requiring
that their children uh that these
parents' children have their own
dedicated email address separate from
and potentially outside of the
supervision of their parents parents are
expected to consent to treatment to pay
medical bills and to make critical
Health Care decisions on behalf of their
children yet they are being denied full
access to the very records that inform
those decisions this is not just
bureaucratic nonsense it is dangerous
how can a parent ensure proper follow-up
care understanded diagnosis or even
recognize potential medical errors when
they are blocked from seeing key details
in their child's medical history the
idea that parents are being treated as
Outsiders in their own Children's Health
Care is an insult to both parental
rights and to Common Sense House Bill
560 corrects this Injustice and ensures
that parents can fulfill their
responsibilities without unnecessary and
arbitrary barriers I urge the committee
to restore sanity and transparency by
recommending this bill for passage thank
you for your time and consideration and
I'm happy to take any questions
questions to the representative
representative Greg I'm just confused
thank you Mr chairman obviously I'm
really confused and uh thank you for
taking my question I'm confused as to
where the having young adults right now
that were just children where is this
happening I've had to consent to
everything that they've had done
medically um I've had to sign off on
that I've been able to get every medical
record without it being redacted like
where do you have specific is there
somebody here maybe that you know that's
going to testify where this has actually
happened so I I think you already heard
precisely that testimony and uh my
understanding in talking with some of
the other Representatives let alone
constituents who are supporting this
legislation is that in circumstances
that they have been seeking precisely
these records as you've heard they have
been denied them or they have been given
redacted records so uh if I am somehow
misunder understanding your question I
apologize but I I think you've already
heard uh the answers on
that representative rice thank you Mr
chairman would you believe that if it
happens to one person it's too many and
this is just good legislation I most
certainly
would any other questions questions
seeing none thank you representative
thank you chair recognizes Ben Bradley
from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association thank you thank you Mr
chairman good morning um my name is Ben
Bradley I'm the vice president of state
government relations for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association I
represent all 26 of the Community
Hospitals in New Hampshire as well as
also specialty hospitals um want to
thank you for the opportunity to testify
and maybe provide some clarity or
Insight um we do have concerns about HP
560 but I want to state that we
completely agree with the general
statement uh of purpose of the bill the
vast majority of P parents absolutely
are acting in their child's best
interests already do have access to
their child's medical record in some
fashion and are responsible for
providing and continuing uh coordinating
Medical Care
however um the bill as written does have
raises some questions for us I'd like to
outline
those
um it does appear to resemble previous
legislation as was mentioned uh and we
continue to believe that it's
unnecessary as uh Hippa already covers
when a med Minor's medical record can be
released uh rather than layer on
additional regulations that raise
serious questions about and
complications we recommend the committee
vote um an expedient to legislate as you
have in the
past a particular concern and what was
talked about previously was uh online
nine including the words including
records available via online patient
portals um to define the medical record
this way creates a technology standard
that currently cannot be met by many
providers in the State uh the bill
acknowledges in section 2A that there
are records protect under federal state
and state laws that parents are not able
to see without their child's consent
such as substance abuse treatment
sexually transmitted disease treatment
reproductive health services and for
emancipated
minors technology limitations of many of
the provids patient portal systems are
not capable of the nuanced parsing of
the medical record to redact these
protected services and therefore we
would provide a hard copy or some other
access uh some other means to the
appropriate information under the
medical
record additionally I want to point out
um under the protective orders clause in
section 2B uh it does raise many
questions about the implementation and
puts healthare providers in a position
to interpret complex legal documents and
postures of the court for one
preliminary protective orders can be
issued without advanced notice to
another party so for example one party
could uh ask for a protective order it
could be issued temporarily or
preliminarily and the other party
wouldn't even know while the subject of
the protective order is entitled to a
hearing to challenge the allegations
that can be days after the initial
order um is the initial order sufficient
to trigger this law or is it after a
contested hearing protective orders also
expire so what happens if an order
expires but nobody tells the healthcare
provider which may be situation likely
to occur what about bail conditions that
include no contact orders would that be
included under this law how would
providers know when the case is resolved
and therefore the order is no longer
valid um what about sentencing orders
and other things that would make it
difficult for the provider to
comply
um there's typically no paperwork that
affirmatively says a case is resolved
and the bail conditions are prob
conditions are lifted so what would be
sufficient documentation for providers
to lift the denial of
access um taking the above into
consideration if the protective order is
no longer valid but nobody tells the
healthc care provider and the hospital
denies access to a parent the hospital
would be in violation of federal
information blocking rules the proposed
language puts the healthcare provider
and the hospital in an untenable
position of having to essentially do a
deep dive into court orders protective
orders bail instructions Etc and so they
can only act on official information
that has been presented to them at the
time of the medical records requests
finally in the last section um we
believe this is also unnecessary as is
the case with respect to all personal
Representatives under Hippa a provider
may choose not to treat a parent as a
personal representative when the
provider reasonably believes in his or
her professional judgment that the child
has been may be subject to domestic
violence abuse neglect or that that
treating the parent as the child's
personal representative could endanger
the child given these concerns we're not
able to support HP 560 but I'm happy to
work with anybody or try to answer any
questions representative D
Simon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my
question uh I'm a parent of three a
grandparent of
four I
cannot
imagine not being told by a pediatrician
who I trusted with my children's care
that there were issues with my child
that my child needed help can you tell
me why this makes sense for a physician
not to tell a parent that their child
has a substance abuse problem where they
could overdose and die at night whether
they have any other issues that need
medical attention where does it make
sense that it's okay not to tell the
parent I think there are existing
statute that outlines uh the limitations
of that and the rights provided to uh
minors at a certain age to protect that
information I can't speak to the the
policy reasoning but I know that that is
the case and has been for a long time
thank you very
much representative rice thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so can you please tell me what doctor's
offices do now if there is a protective
order that's brought in is this
something they can't comprehend I don't
understand why that would be difficult
do they want I mean if that protective
order runs runs out now it's still going
to run out who's who's telling them and
and what is the policy no I think they
they act on the information that is
presented to them um I think this
statute does
um nail down the uh qualifications in a
way that makes it clear especially if as
I mentioned the protective order goes
away and nobody's told the provider how
are they to know that the patient the
parent now does have access so I will
just reiterate that they act on the
information that's provided to them to
their best of their ability and
assume that the parent is acting in the
best interest of of the parent of the
patient of the minor child unless
there's some indication otherwise their
professional judgment or some
information is presented to them I think
the bill as it's written just outlines
some um broad swath circumstances that
just make it a little more difficult uh
than simply their ability to take the
information that they have and be able
to make a determination as to whether uh
the parent would appropriately have
access
followup thank you Mr chairman
so I don't I'm I'm having trouble
connecting this because if a parent
comes in with the with the protective
order yet say it's good for a year it
expires but they don't come back and
tell the The Physician you're still
having that same problem that's true
thank you true this codifies that
problem into state
law representative
Petrino thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question certainly um if
I'm hearing this correctly I think a big
concern uh is the portal and that
technology uh at the moment is not
capable of redacting certain information
that by law needs to be redacted but
true parents still have access
with a hard copy if requested is that
correct hard copy and electronically by
means that are outside of the portal in
a way that record a record could be sent
to them electronically but also redacted
appropriately uh to be in compliance
with the existing statute thank you very
much representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um the this um idea uh this
problem of Technology not catching up to
um the the desires of many parents in
the state has come up uh several times
in the past uh are you aware of any
fixes to the current software that would
address this
issue um there may be developments in
the future I'm not aware of those but um
at this point all I can testify to is
the technology
limitations uh that aren't able to parse
that out on the portal
itself representative Raymond thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question if this bill were to pass with
the language changes to align the burden
of proof to what everything else is um
what would the hospital system do for
their portal would they simply say
portals aren't available for teenagers
anymore or would they be like invest
millions in developing the technology I
think it's a good good question um in
order to be in compliance with the law
if the portal hasn't kept up or become
capable of parsing out um the protected
information then I would assume which is
a risky thing to do uh I would assume
that uh it would be difficult to provide
access to the portal altogether um but
as I said I think providers do make
every effort when a medical record
request is made to provide the
appropriate access it may not just not
be um through the patient portal which
is for the which is for the individual's
medical you know
use thank
you seeing no further questions thank
you so much Mr Bradley thank you Mr
chair and most everybody else on a pink
card has asked to speak for three
minutes and so given the time uh we will
put the three minute rule in if uh
numbers of these people can do it in
three the rest of you can too and one of
the best speeches I heard in this room
was 47 seconds long needless to say I
didn't give it the chair recognizes
Cassandra Sanchez from the office of
child advocate with hand outs of
cour good morning once again for the
record Cassandra Sanchez child advocate
for the State of New Hampshire um and
yes we are passing out some written test
testimony um I am here before you in
opposition of House Bill
560 um some of the points have been
touched on already particularly the um
clear and convincing evidence is very
concerning um to hold uh medical
providers to that standard um so I won't
drown on about that um but also another
concern um that I hold for this bill is
that um when we were talking about
medical records this is also inclusive
uh not only of the the safe space that
children should have with their medical
providers but this is also inclusive of
therapeutic records because those are
considered Med medical records um it is
really important for children to have a
space where they can share about what is
happening in their lives to adults that
can act protectively for them um
doctor's offices I can speak from
personal experience whenever I bring my
child to the doctor's office they have a
conversation right in front of my face
asking are you safe what is happening in
your home has there been any domestic
violence that is important conversations
to really assess whether the child is
safe in their home environment and when
they reach a certain age um and have the
Privacy to do that with their medical
professional it may not rise to level
abuse or neglect but it may be something
noteworthy that goes into their chart
and with parents having direct access
that could become a dangerous situation
for a
child I also want to share um an
experience that we had in a a case um
that we were overseeing for DCF um so
you may already be aware but I want to
make sure it is very clear that um
parents who have their children removed
from their Care by the division maintain
their rights which means they still have
access and they still are in
decision-making roles of their children
when it comes to medical um and
educational 30 seconds and what that
means is that they have direct access to
their medical records we had a parent
that had a founded allegation against
them for abuse of their child and that
very parent was using the access to the
medical records through the online
system to continue to manipulate that
child although that child was in the
care of the division the division can
bring these things to court in which
they ultimately did but it is not
immediate so in that interim this parent
was manipulating this child was
canceling out providers and removing
releases so the child was not receiving
appropriate care was accessing
medications and removing the child from
medications without the appropriate
tapering down from the medication that's
required by the medical professional
to the point that the medical
professionals themselves said they could
no longer treat that child because the
level of manipulation and control that
was happening was so dangerous that they
did not feel it was appropriate for them
to provide care to that child so this
also happens to our children in
care questions
for The Advocate you're going to have to
turn your mic back on representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you for coming to speak to us
about this I I didn't realize until
until you said it that this would apply
to therapeutic records and so my
question is about um a Supreme Court
case in reberg uh New Hampshire 658
2005 um which talks about how parents
don't it was a Supreme Court decision so
parents don't have the right to a
child's confidential therapeutic records
would this bill override that Supreme
Court
case it would um or be in conflict with
it it would be in conflict with that and
I do believe my understanding and if I
misspeak please somebody correct me but
my understanding is that um once
legislation is changed after that the
legisl the new legislation would Trump
that prior Court
decision any other
questions for The Advocate seeing none
thank you thank
you the chair recognizes Kathy Stratton
from the New Hampshire Medical societ
y did we get the handouts
from the previous speaker did they all
did they go byy me and
I you did your job I did my job you did
all right oh yes I did get it I didn't
do my job sorry here we go thank you Mr
chairman here's your hand thank you very
very
much okay that was on my clock you may
go got to turn the mic
on it's on now excellent um check my
watch good morning it's still morning um
and I will preempt the question I will
submit my testimony electronically after
this um my name is Kathy Stratton and
I'm the New Hampshire Medical Society
CEO
um and I'm here to speak in opposition
of House Bill
560 um I want to State clearly first of
all that Physicians value the role that
parents play in the treatment team the
care and the protection of minors um the
society however has concerns that as
proposed this legislation would
interfere with the physician patient
relationship under Hippa parents already
have access to the miners medical
records and exceptions under the federal
law address important safety needs of
the miners in effectively balancing the
needs of Guardians with those of miners
who need protection and additional
confidentiality again in the majority of
cases parents are
valued in valued part of the minor
healthc care team when considering this
bill our physicians were concerned that
under the bill some some vulnerable
miners who could not be guaranteed a
level of confidentiality would either
avoid or delay medical or Behavioral
Health Care delays in physical health
care often result in more complicated
and more costly Medical Care sometimes
resulting in irreparable health issues
as a result I want to also highlight the
impact that this bill could have on
Behavioral Health Care of minors
confidentiality is Paramount to
treatment and for treatment to be
effective the patient must be able to
disclose behaviors thoughts and feelings
without fear of judgment or punishment
imagine how intimidating it would be to
worry that what you said um would be
revealed to those who you would want to
not to disclose that information too um
this committee is responsible for the
laws that govern many of New Hampshire's
most vulnerable populations I believe
that the additional barriers in this
bill
um to New Hampshire's most vulnerable
populations um
I'm so
sorry I believe that the physicians in
our communities are are vital to
protection of this population and I urge
you not to support measures that would
effectively increase barriers to
physical and behavioral health care
thank you for your time and
consideration of my testimony thank you
do you take questions representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thanks
for taking my call
um not taking into consider
consideration therapeutic or other
things that we talked about that needed
to be redacted I'm a little bit confused
because um how would this become more
dangerous when a parent can at any time
ask ask for um hard copies um so what
would be the difference between
obtaining um information that is
currently um acceptable to obtain
through hard copy versus that of online
p
information I didn't I didn't address
the hard copy it was more I was I was
talking to the burden of proof um where
a physician a a a minor may not feel
like they would have the confidentiality
to come in to address certain physical
or Behavioral healthc Care issues thank
you representative love thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um I guess this is a would you
believe would you believe that many many
many prescribed drugs uh lead to lead to
abuse of of uh similar drugs uh for
instance Aderall um you know my my
daughter was was was prescribed Aderall
in the seventh or eighth grade and by
the time she was a a sophomore in high
school her and all her friends that were
uh were prescribed it also crushing them
up and snorting them uh she took us on a
7-year run uh smok and crack and ended
up doing heroin it was a a run through
hell and uh don't you think that the
parents should have had I mean my my
ex-wife thought it was okay I wouldn't
have approved don't you think I should
have had a little bit of say in this and
I wasn't entitled to to it uh that's a
could you comment on it I'm very Touched
By Your Story um and I and I worked for
several years in the
recovery field um with um actually
medical professionals who recovering
from abuse um you know I'm not involved
in that
patient relationship so I'm not sure
that I can speak to that right now um
and and again we're not here to to put
barriers we're here to protect the our
our vulnerable populations the children
um and and you know again I'm so sorry
for
that followup question representative
love wouldn't it be safe to say that
12 to 17 year old children make bad Mist
bad decisions uh you know G given the
the uh if if they're given
narcotics to to uh for any reason
whatsoever uh don't you think that they
make bad decisions and they should be
should have both parents making helping
them I will leave that I I can't
disagree as a parent of of three adult
children um who have made some
questionable decisions
um you know I will say that again we're
here to speak to those vulnerable
populations and I and I can't speak to
the situation of why a physician in in
this particular situation wouldn't have
disclosed it or what what the
particulars are um you know we value the
role of parents and our physicians
really want to engage with parents um
we're speaking about maybe that small
percentage of children who actually who
very much need
that
confidentiality representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um kind of along the
I the lines of things that are already
protected and redacted as per state law
like substance abuse and reproductive
Health choices um would this
bill be in would this bill prohibit
practitioners in mass in New Hampshire
from following the state law that
requires those things to be
redacted I'm not an attorney I think we
would have to consult an attorney as to
what which would preempt and what how
this would play out I I can't speak to
that okay thanks I'm
sorry representative Coen thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for uh being here
to answer our questions um I just want
to ask you your opinion is is it more
important that we prioritize the patient
doctor relationship over the parent
child
relationship thank you for the question
you're going to it's you guys are
hitting me hard today um these are these
are very very challenging questions and
I think I will tell you that the
Physicians that that I spoke with in
regards to this
um don't take these decisions lightly
and they think very carefully um I can't
get
into what the nuances of of Any Given
decision or or you know I think that
there there are good questions that are
coming out here um and as a parent I
wanted to be involved and and again I
will say I was always asked for my
permission and and I was never denied
access to my kids records um and and and
I can understand that in certain
circumstances um you know you as
legislators might might question that
but I think having the ability to to act
protectively is important you know we
don't want to look back and say oh gosh
that level of protection should have
been afforded to that child because now
there's been a devastating consequence
so I think we're coming at it
conservatively from a patient and
physician perspective
thank you for your
testimony if she's comfortable with it
could you answer that question where a
lawyer was
needed neither am I thank
you representative Betty gay
representative we are on a clock either
sit down or please um give your
testimony one of the
other okay the part of Representative
gay is being played by representative
kofalt in tonight's performance okay
thank you thank you Mr chairman and if I
uh if you can tell me where to get a a
blank pink card I will hand one in after
my testimony appreciate that making one
thank you sir um so for the record my
name is Jim k
I uh represent Hillsboro District 32 uh
representing the towns of Wilton Temple
and new ipswitch um so I am uh quite
familiar with this uh issue we had this
bill uh two years ago in health and
human services and um it seems that it
is a recurring issue I think at the time
we had retained the bill and in the
hopes that this would be addressed at a
federal level um because there was at
the time something called the
information blocking rule uh under
consideration by the office of civil
rights which um enforces
Hippa um I understand that there are uh
challenges there are some technical
challenges with implementing something
like this having said that um since we
have not seen any action at the federal
level to um Implement changes that would
require parents to have um adequate
access to their Children's Medical
records and portal access to set
appointments for example um I think it's
important that we uh move this bill
forward in order to affect some change
um I spoke to a parent uh just two days
ago who called me about this bill and
said that um she is actually being told
that since her son has turned 12 she no
longer has access that neither of them
has access to the portal um and she is
now unable to make appointments even she
she can't just get her son's um
credentials and use them and go online
and make an appointment there is no
access at all and so uh that is creating
a a barrier it's creating an
inconvenience um I know that parents who
want their children's medical records
can can get those uh pursuant to Hippa
uh but there's an extensive process of
redacting information information from
that um and making sure that um any
protected information that may be
safeguarded by federal law state law or
both is is redacted so that the Privacy
is not um violated 30 seconds um I'll
just wrap up I think it's important for
us to keep uh to keep the pressure on
and move toward a solution and I think
this bill helps to do that thank you
very much questions for the
representative representative
patrino thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question you mentioned parents uh
inability to make appointments for their
children uh they still able to pick up a
telephone and make a call to schedule an
appointment um thank you for the
question
so if if the provider or facility is
taking appointments by phone yes um I
was told by this particular parent that
she is being directed to use a
smartphone she does not have a
smartphone um
to make the appointment so I am not
familiar with the the particular
mechanism that they were asking her to
use it was not the patient portal it was
something else um and there's some
frustration that this is um causing her
to jump through some additional
Hoops thank you
representative chair
recognizes I'm going to say
Viking
Hedberg my norwegian's a bit Rusty how
did I
do quite well actually Viking is not a
real name in Sweden but it's was my
grandfather's you're Swedish I so no the
I I beg your pardon there's an issue
across the L yes I do and I appreciate
the opportunity to come before you today
I am a pediatrician who's been
practicing in New Hampshire since
1997 I also did after my three-year
pediatric residency I also did a
three-year Fellowship in adolescent
medicine and this issue about privacy is
really
challenging and I'm testifying an
opposition of this bill um and I hear
your concerns very much about parental
involvement and there's no way I think
clinicians are trying to decrease
parental involvement you know I work
very hard trying to keep parents
involved in productive ways with their
kids and building
relationships the challenge with this
bill well there's two things there's one
it's unnecessary because hip is quite
clear their parents do have access and
the issue trying to be solved
legislatively here is one of technology
and organizational policy I'm only
representing myself but I believe
Dartmouth Hitchcock both parent and
child has access to the portal but it's
able to be separated in Epic their
electronic system I work for conquered
Hospital which has Cerner which doesn't
have that ability so they just shut it
down it is is incredibly frustrating
it's frustrating to me as a clinician
it's frustrating to parents but it's not
a legal issue it's an issue of being
able to solve the problem the one thing
that Hippa has in it that this doesn't
is it allows parents
to deputize their children to have
access now no places doing that but
there's no magic when you hit your 18th
birthday you develop maturity I can tell
you a lot of 19-year-old males whose
frontal loes I do not trust one bit um
so it's a process of development and I
think there have to be thoughtful ways
within our profession where we gradually
hand control and ability over to the
young people and that's a healthy
progress that happens happens in schools
happens in communities this half a
minute doctor thank you this bill blocks
that and it's also unneeded because
there is access I'll last leave one
other thing is we get asked really
bizarre questions in the office I've
been asked if I masterbate does my penis
get longer and if I was my parent was
reading that I think I would be pretty
embarrassed so I want to protect privacy
I want kids to be able to talk to me
without fear that what they say is going
to be put verbatim back to the parents
one other thing is Cerner is B bought by
Oracle they're now going to be using AI
to transcribe our visits it's going to
open up a
whole other issue of what goes into
those records and how we edit them
doctor will you take questions I would
be happy to take questions
questions representative Raymond uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um
so my question is about the technology
piece because I was kind of baffled by
some of the previous testimony because
my child is 16 and I was in his parent
portal this his patient portal this
weekend reconciling his PT bill with his
PT dates being like why are these not
the same we figured it out so my
question is is there um a is there a
cost issue with the various systems like
why is there such disparities between
these technological systems between
hospitals that's a very big question
and these systems are huge they're
incredibly expensive they're incredibly
expensive to implement and they are
not necessarily efficient nor designed
to do what they actually have to do some
are much better than
others thank you doctor thank you you
may be interested to know I absolutely
despise poal and refuse to be on any of
them could I answer that question that
wasn't a question that was a parting
shot but sure can I comment on that as
the son of a of my father who
passed um I had to be on every one of
his portals to make sure care was
appropriate and there were prescrib
medicines that were contraindicated
including one that was prescribed by a
cardiologist that increased his rate of
risk of death by
50% and if I wasn't diligent he would
have been given things that were
problematic now it's hard because our
health system is really complicated it's
really in
silos I wish it worked better know but
without that portal he would have not
been with us nearly the length of time
that he was and that I was grateful for
thank you Doctor very
much what I learned from that is I'll
make sure my children are chair
recognizes anarie
Banfield thank you
for roughly three
minutes thank you for the record anary
Banfield I'm a parental rights advocate
in New Hampshire and I focus on
education but I felt compelled to come
to this um this hearing first of all
Bedford uh years ago I asked them to put
their check registry online and they
just did it and they redact everything
that needs to be redacted so I'm not
sure how a school can do it but a
medical facil facility
cannot uh insurance companies get our
medical records get the medical records
and now we're just basically saying no
to parents again showing the
difference
um also there was a Supreme Court ruling
I think it was Timberlane where they
were asking for timberlan schools were
asking for electronic records and they
had to go to the Supreme Court and
Supreme Court said yes you you have to
give electronic records if a parent asks
for that or somebody files it through a
91a um the the term dangerous was
brought up and by the way I do get a lot
of uh comments from parents about this I
had no idea my my adult my children are
adults I had no idea that that this was
even happening um but because I'm a
parental rights Advocate I do hear from
parents that they're not able to access
this information but we heard the term
dangerous it's going to be dangerous to
provide this information to parents
although they can get it through through
electronical record so if a if a child
comes in is talking about his penis
enlarging they would be able to get it
through written records so I'm not sure
what what that what that correlation was
um but you know I go in and I normally
don't share personal information but I
go in every 3 months for photomy I've
got a blood disorder so my blood's thick
I don't know how to describe it in
medical terms so I go in every 3 months
for photomy because if my hemoglobin
level goes up too high and I have a
stroke um that would cause more medical
problems so if my hemoglobin level is at
a certain level um I will if I have a
stroke I should be able to survive it in
a better way so knowing that my blood
has that disorder if my daughter who is
now 30 had gone in to seek birth control
at an early age and I know that that
information's redacted you literally
would have put her in life dangering
position I can't take birth control I
couldn't take birth control cuz that is
that's a ticket to stroke and that's a
ticket to blood clots and that's a
ticket to death so yeah there are simple
simple um there are medical problems
that people have that if they're cut if
if I would have been cut out of the half
a minute cut out of the scene you would
put her life in
danger and my son was in a hospital for
2 weeks blood clots everywhere during Co
he's lucky to be alive because he had it
clearly he clearly has it so my point is
you talk about
danger you put my daughter on on birth
control without running a this blood
test and I wouldn't have known I had
this blood testc but because I went
through a kidney transplant I had to
have this blood work done and that's
where they found it thank you Miss
bfield uh any questions for the witness
uh representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question would you believe you're not
the only person who has encountered this
issue I
myself um took hormones um
for change of life uh transition let's
say um and I ended up with a saddle
pulmonary embolism which is nearly fatal
and it's usually not discovered until
autopsy and it's vitally important that
my
daughter tells every physician because
it is an
unknown reason why I have this issue
although my father and my grandmother
have it as well so would you believe
that you are not the only person with
this issue oh absolutely I mean you you
talk about a vulnerable population I
keep hearing the term vulnerable
population what about the vulnerable
parents out there that are being cut out
what about those parents and what about
their children we talk about vulnerable
we got to we got a protect these
vulnerable kids well you're not
protecting my daughter with this kind
of redacted information question
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you would you
believe that as a survivor of multiple
Strokes I told my 13-year-old daughter
about the risks about birth control so
that as she transitions into adulthood
she can make responsible and intelligent
choices and have confidential discussion
questions with her doctor would you
believe that parents have an obligation
to parent their children and not leave
out important information that would
allow their child to
survive uh thank you for the question I
don't think that the disparaging kind of
remarks that you just made in your
facial expressions was necessary um but
in in addition to that yes I would tell
my daughter
there's not always the correlation I
didn't have a stroke to to share that
information thankfully we caught it
before that actually happened and yes
she's aware now but at the age of 16
this is when they were running the tests
on me this is when the they were they
were finding out this information about
me because I had my kidney transplant 14
years ago she's 30 now so in that time
frame what I've had the the knowledge at
that moment maybe not at that moment but
maybe at that moment maybe I wouldn't
have put it together my point is now
that I do know of course my daughter
knows my daughter's a nurse practitioner
she sees all the people coming in with
who who've had covid who have had
Strokes who have had blood clots and who
understand now that putting them on a
birth control pill comes at
risk thank you for your testimony chair
now recognizes Betty gay former state
representative since we're all probably
getting hungry at this point I really
will be brief okay Betty gay from Salem
and six years ago I was presenting well
no I didn't even get to present because
they double booked me I didn't get to
present this law this rule uh bill but
this is the third time it's being
presented okay we handed out uh some
tables that are uh include among other
things the Federal
confidentiality Rec uh rules so we can't
overcome them but we can overcome the
New Hampshire confidentiality rules that
this bill is trying to
address okay so you have you have that
and that's your leisure you can choose
which ones are meaningful to you excuse
me uh Unfortunately they combined New
Hampshire and federal so you have to
read it quite carefully to figure out
but most of it and I wish my voice would
stop shaking but I'm trying to talk
really fast
uh okay so for one thing there's a
difference between Federal and New
Hampshire and we're trying to be
respectful of the federal but we want to
get rid of the New Hampshire
confidentiality rules that are being so
harmful to families with teens and a lot
of the issues that are being discussed
would apply to Children younger than 1
to so some some of the arguments are
have holes in them um there are
safeguards written into this bill so
under Roman numeral 2 B and C definitely
give people in Authority who have access
to this information the right to prevent
parents from accessing it if they think
it's
dangerous we're also talking about the M
Mass majority of children have parents
who are responsible and where the
hindrances built that are in the system
right now are hindering the majority of
people rather than be protective of the
few kids who really do have parents who
somebody should be separating their
Authority from the child so both B and C
are really really important and refute a
lot of the arguments that are being
presented against this bill
um yes I've already said all ages of
children some of these arguments apply
to so this this bill is not uh doesn't
really solve those issues for age um 20
seconds clear and convincing evidence
definitely can be amended and it sounds
like it's going to be there is not only
Hippa but furpa which I'm not familiar
with but the Federal uh Records cite it
as a very important document about
children's records
um and if an older child needs to let
their doctor know something they don't
want their parents to hear they've got a
telephone also you don't have to put
every single thing in a record of these
what sounds funny questions of a child
asking their doctor that doesn't have to
be in the record thank you
representative amerita
and uh that you did got a lot of words
packed in there I know you normally
speak slowly any questions for The
Honorable Betty gay representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
honorable gay for being here and taking
my question because you've worked on
this legislation numerous times as
you've said and you've had it before and
we're assuming that the majority of the
parents are good parents who have
healthy relationships what is it about
this bill or what is it about what's
happening in the world that these good
parents are not able to have
conversations about the medical part of
the kids' lives and be able to um
already see their records and stuff I
know that I know that I can I assume I'm
an okay parent because I can do all that
so I'm just wondering what is what is
stopping parents from having
conversations with their
kids I'm thinking about how difficult it
is to get your child to get say you have
a perfect relationship with your child
and they don't know what's protected
they don't know that you're that you
can't find out if they ask for birth
control pills because the federal
prohibitions are on that what if they're
afraid to tell you and also can you
imagine getting your child to give
permission to every single provider that
they hear and make sure that the
communication doesn't break down I I
really feel like since you haven't
experienced it you're having a hard time
believing what's happening to most
parents
follow up would you believe I have
experienced this because of my um
relationship with my late husband and I
do have continual conversations with my
children so that they're not scared to
talk to me well that's certainly the
goal for all of
us representative
Nelson thank you Mr thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
call my call that's twice now but that's
good we're really getting hungry here
question always do that I don't know why
I keep saying that
um would you believe that despite my uh
warning my daughter about uh the need to
discuss um low estrogen or high
progesterone birth control with their
doctor starting when
I thankfully did not pass away from a
pulmonary embolism and I kept repeating
it to her that when at the age of 15 she
went to obtain birth control I had no
Knowledge from the doctor of what type
of birth control she was
on I do believe it and the sad thing is
that under federal law you still
wouldn't be able to know that unless
unless your daughter told you we can't
change the federal law but at least we
can change the New Hampshire
law thank you thank you
question is there any sorry thank you
for taking my
call question well you're welcome
representative Malone carry
on sorry um is there anything preventing
parents now whether they have a good
relationship or poor relationship with
their teenage child to still give the
doctor that medical
history um that these drugs could be
dangerous to my child in the future at 7
years old 8 years old 10 years old so
that information's already there so the
doctor could have that conversation with
the child if the child's not listening I
don't see anything in this in this bill
that would prohibit the parent from
giving information to the doctor
it's just the parent might not know who
the child is even seeing until they get
a
bill do do we know if that's like a
sorry followup that's
what do we I don't even know how to
question
this do we know how like how often is
this like really happening because like
again like to me I bring my kid to the
doctor and I was there and we had the
conversation about birth control for a
period cramp she's going to hate that
this was
bu um
but but we had those conversations and I
just always remember those providers so
are these like oneoff providers like
maybe just a a sexual health provider
versus their PHP they the person that
their pediatrician that they've always
seen I have an experienced it
unfortunate and I know that right and we
think that most people would not if
these if these prohibitions were
stopped it's just the prohibition is
there there's a lot of ignorance implied
and um it's just not good parenting to
be told your child is now turned 13
so you can pay the bills but you really
are not supposed to be
involved thank
you thank
you and the chair now recognizes Matthew
Hood thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Matthew Hood I'm the vice president of
government relations at Dartmouth health
I promise I will be quick
um I wanted to start by saying how um
much value and emphasis the providers uh
in the Pediatrics and primary medicine
place on the engagement of parents in
their children's health um we strongly
encourage that uh in a Minor's care and
we also want to be mindful of those
scenarios where that could either be
problematic or is pro prohibited
that being said what I was hoping to
emphasize for the committee today is
things that have already been said so
this the differing standards between the
federal law um and the state law at
least as in the current version of the
amendment clear and convincing evidence
is something that we would like to work
with the committee on uh remedying um
because we find compliance with two
standards to be a somewhat challenging
proposal I think to the um chairs what I
heard to be the chairs earlier comment
about wanting to provide Clarity with
respect to what parents are enabled as
well as the parameters about when that's
not totally on board with helping to
facilitate that process um and
finally I can't speak to the portal um
my daughter turns 12 in May so I will be
able to speak to the portal situation
fairly soon I suppose um uh but happy to
pursue any uh the answers to that
question from the dmouth health
perspective if that would be
helpful my sense is that uh there's some
good stuff in this Bill Good Intentions
and some work needs to be done and it
would be very helpful because I don't
have access immediately to it to
actually have the hip of regulations as
they exist and not as people think they
exist and that's all over the map and
compare contrast to the state rules and
um if you want to be an adviser to
somebody I uner you to them because this
could be a good thing thank you Mr
chairman for the opportunity I would be
happy to do so or delegate my colleague
Courtney Tanner um who's probably
listening at the moment to participate
in that process as well representative
rice thank you Mr chairman please see me
after the meeting thank you and is your
name pronounced hood or
Hood I always feel like I should write
in parenthetical h o d um it's Hood
thank you Mr chair that would be helpful
thank you any questions for Mr
doctor Mr Matthew either one's good
that's
fine now that we've got your name sorted
out there's no
questions thank you for volunteering
your help and with this I close the
hearing on HB 560 Bona
Petit
e
e e
yeah right I'm out like thank you like
to open the hearing on House Bill
661 FN an act relative to the Department
of Health and Human Services management
of Social Security payments supplemental
security income payments and veterans
benefits for children and foster care
and the chair recognizes representative
Mary Jane
walner the prime sponsor
thank you chairman Pearson and members
of the committee I'm Mary Jane walner
and I'm a state representative from
conquer and my district is pretty much
right across the street you can almost
see it from here um in September of
2023 NPR ran a a story entitled kids get
the bill for their own f F care and
Nationwide 5 to 10% of children in
Children and Youth in foster care
qualify for Social Security disability
or survivors
benefits these are children who have had
a parent that died or a parent who is
disabled or a child who themselves has a
disability Across the Nation including
New Hampshire the state have retained
these benefits when a child goes into
foster care but that is changing many
states are moving to preserve the
benefits for the foster child making
sure benefits are held securely for the
child until they are no longer in care
last year I brought in House Bill
1598 which would have change the New
Hampshire practice of the state
retaining the child's benefits to
reimburse the state date for the child's
care this committee overwhelmingly
passed the legislation and when it
reached the finance committee there were
many questions from both legislators and
state Personnel on how the new policy
would
work so House Bill 1598 from last year
was amended to provide the Department of
Health and Human Services with funding
to hire a consultant to develop a report
and a roadmap appap as to how New
Hampshire can implement this polic new
policy in December of 2024 just a couple
of months ago the report entitled child
centered benefits management assessment
was completed and provides New Hampshire
with the information and process needed
to enact this
policy I have made copies of the
findings from the findings pages of the
report for each of you and I've got one
for for all of you um and I'm leaving a
copy of the full report with your
committee to um and I'd be glad if any
of you want your own copy of this I
would be glad to make a copy of it and
and get it to you um I would like to
urge the committee to pass this
legislation so it can go to the finance
committee the finance committee
obviously worked on this bill last year
and made a decision to put in a sizable
amount of money to hire a national
consultant to come in and help New
Hampshire with what would need what
would need to happen in order for this
uh policy to take place so the bill
really needs to be in finance so that
Finance can continue to explore this
policy so I believe the hurdle for this
bill is um a financial one and it needs
to go to the house finance committee and
I hope you will vote to move the bill
along there are many people here today
who can provide testimony on the bill
including at least one young person the
state policy has affected you will hear
that the difference what a difference
these benefits will make in the lives of
children leaving foster care I recently
visited a homeless shelter in Manchester
that is for youth ages 18 to
24 and the staff told us that about 40%
% of the young people in the shelter
have been in the State Trial protection
system foster care or in residential
placement think of the difference it
would make in the lives of young people
if their benefit have been preserved so
that when they enter adult life with
they will have a chance of going to
college having a place to live affording
a car so they can get employment being
in state custody is hard enough for a
child sorry about
that without without losing the benefits
that provide them a safety net as they
enter adulthood so I hope that I can
urge you to pass this on so that we can
have a discussion in finance about of
the financial issues around this bill
and the details to how we would put this
in place notwithstanding the motto
finances where good bills go to die it
would seem that uh Finance has done a
wonderful job upfront so when it comes
back to them they should be quite
excited that was a would you believe yes
I would believe that they yeah I'm going
to hand out um the findings pages so I
have one for each of you and I also have
um um the report I for the clerk okay
good thank you so I will bring this up I
I will answer questions if you have any
for the
representative representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative wner for taking my
question um so I was trying to remember
last year all the discussions we had
about this spill um and one of the the
questions that I had last year and I
still have is about um circumstances
where the child's parent or some other
relative is already the paye for the
social security benefit benefits and is
using that money to pay for things like
the family's rent so that the child has
a place to come back would this bill
interfere with that process and then
secondarily if the circumstance were to
arise where the pay ends up being
changed to the state um well just that
one would that one would they interfere
with
it well it would it would mean that the
the benefits would be preserved for the
child by the state and the state would
no longer take those benefits for the
state's uh reimbursement for the for the
Foster Care you will see that there is
one difference one small difference in
this bill than there was last time and
we added and I don't have the bill up
here with me but we did add a section
that refers to if a child goes into
foster care and they already have a paye
might be a
relative um a family friend um a
grandparent it you know if the child
already has a pay and the state
determines that that is an appropriate
pay they could retain that paye okay dur
while they are in foster care and that
would avoid the state taking the the uh
Social Security payment so thank you
that's where I was trying to go follow
um so in that circumstance would the
would that pay still have the ability to
use those funds to maintain the child's
existing you know household of origin or
does that pay then have to create um a
savings account for the child with those
funds I think that I think that would be
something that I would imagine that the
Department of Health and Human Services
would work out with the pay I mean in
some
circumstances If the child has had these
Social Security payments and the family
is very lowincome and they they may be
using part of the child's Social
Security to help pay their rent if you
really want to reunify the family you
don't want to impoverished them in such
a way that they couldn't accept the
child back into the family so this could
benefit the reunification of families by
being sure that those resources are
preserved with the family thank you
that's what I was trying to get clarity
on thank you any further questions for
representative walner saying none thank
you so
much and uh you know every one of these
cards with two exceptions says you want
to speak for three minutes and the two
exceptions say two minutes and since
we've got other things we got to do this
afternoon I'm going to hold you to 3
minutes when you hit one minute I'm
going to go like that which is which is
not a sign that I'm smarter than you
believe me and then two and then I might
give you a 30 second um warning let's
say uh that's just so we can keep things
moving along chair recognizes Karen
Rosenberg from the disability
rights Center and I did have one
question for representative
walner do you get mileage
so like Jim McKay huh yeah yeah
you did I get one thank you I don't
think I got one I didn't get one I want
one H good afternoon chairman Pearson
and members of the committee I'm Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director of the
disability rights Center of New
Hampshire and we are here in strong
support of this spell as you've heard
from representative walner um HB 661
would require the department of um
Health and Human Services to help um
parents apply for benefits for their
children or apply for federal benefits
for children in their custody and then
require that those benefits you be
conserved they could be used for current
needs that exceed what our foster care
system generally covers for children
which for children with disabilities
could be things like extra supports and
rest bit in the family home the Foster
family home um that aren't generally
covered by the regular foster care
benefit or system or not covered by
Medicaid um it would also require the
department to allow those benefits to be
conserved for the child um for their
future use for children who are have
disabilities and are eligible for SSI or
supplemental security income that is a
um income-based disability program
um for children and adults but it has a
resource limit um those funds could
could be conserved in an account called
an able account or sometimes referred to
as a stable account very easy to use
every our state has one and that the
money could be safe for future use and
without impacting a child's eligibility
for continuing SSI
benefits the reasons we think this is
really important policy for our children
is that we expect significant ly
improved outcomes for children who have
um contact with the Foster or the um DCF
um for children who are removed from
their parents for children who
ultimately age out of the system um the
best outcome of course for children when
there is a suggestion that they might be
subjected to some abuse or neglect would
be for the family to get the services
they need to stay intact to not have the
children removed having those benefits
available helping Ames to apply for
these benefits can help maintain family
stability help them maintain food and
nutrition and housing for the child if
children need to be removed due to
safety concerns having those benefits
available can help with reunification or
also help entice a kinship family to
actually house a child knowing that they
can get the rest that they might need
for a child with disability or other
services or supports that they would
need to maintain the child safely 30
seconds oh my goodness I know so I have
provided two documents for you one is
from Casey Family Services which is a
chart that outlines um children who exit
foster care um what our homeless rate is
compared to the um rest of the country
and you'll see um that right now 45% of
New Hampshire children 19 years old exit
the system homeless this would prevent
that from happening I've also circulated
testimony from a youth who was in foster
care Kamaya Lockett who couldn't be here
today she um did experience homelessness
um and is eligible for SSI benefits um
and would not have experienced
homelessness with these benefits I
noticed the not so subtle hinge chairman
Pearson I'm happy to answer any
questions encourage you to support this
bill she's very happy because your igles
just won the Super Bowl she is too yes
don't speak Philadelphia not in my
committee okay go ahead representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman and um
thank you for that I don't actually know
about the Eagles but I'm happy for
anyone who's
happy um so do can I just ask about the
chart you gave us um which is the from
2021 is that when the data is from 2021
the most recent data I um accessed it
today actually it was dated um for it
actually has a date of June 2024 so when
they published it okay um so does that
mean that almost half of the kids who
are leaving foster care don't have a
place to go when they walk out at 18 or
not necessarily it means that they
during some time between the ages in
this chart between the ages of 17 and 19
they experienced homelessness so maybe
they had a place to go right when they
exited but then they didn't have a place
during the interim couple of years that
this reports on and it doesn't mean just
to be clear that they necessarily were
eligible for SSI it just shows this is
just one outcome point for our children
in foster care and something this bill
could do to prevent this kind of outcome
it's horrifying thank
you any further questions seeing none
thank you so much the igles are the
Philadelphia Eagles and they won the
Super Bowl yesterday yeah I'm not really
a sports ball person good for everybody
else though you two can talk
later chair recognizes Stacy
Phillips and and we got 3
minutes okay now I have three children
to talk about so I'll try okay I am here
to talk about HB 661 my name is Stacy
Phillips I live in Manchester New
Hampshire my husband and I were foster
parents from 2004 to around 2011 during
this time we fostered around 73 children
we were trained as regular specialized
in an emergency home and we did respit
we adopted two children from Foster Care
um I also feel it's important to share a
little bit of my background cuz I feel
it gives me a unique look at this
specific situation and legislation I
have my associates in early childhood
education human services and a
bachelor's in psychology with a minor in
education for I worked 10 years as a
preschool kindergarten teacher four
years as a par ofprofessional to special
needs children and I currently work for
the state as a disability examiner
working for Social Security disability
so very wide gam it my youngest adopted
child was placed with me at 8 months old
she was failur to Thrive could not roll
over sit up hold her own bottle or feed
herself she was severely de delayed in
De developmental mild Stones while under
my care she slowly made gains but was
non-verbal still at two knowing what I
know now she clearly met criteria for
Social Security disability the regular
foster care statement was all we
received for this child for most of her
time and Care the Staten did not
remotely cover the extensive things this
child
needed the $300 our sensory swing that
hung in our hallway the stretchy sacks
the weighted blankets are just a few of
the things that we had to pay out of
pocket I also had to drop down to
part-time work because of OT PT speech
IEP meetings blah blah blah blah um her
aggression issues would rise to the
level that windows and Furniture would
be broken pretty much on a monthly basis
we knew the day we adopted her that we
she would likely never live without our
support and we would need to plan for
when we leave this earth having
disability funds would have helped
greatly offset the out of pocket
expenses to meet just her basic needs
never mind plan for the
future as foster parents we had no right
to apply for Social Security
disability when she attained age 18 I
did apply for adult child with the
disability survivors benefits under m l
husband's Social Security record she was
found meeting criteria for autism um and
was allowed disability benefits which
supports my theory that she would have
been allowed as a child um my other
adopted child came to us she was in care
for two plus years before she was
adopted we found out the state was
receiving her benefits from Social
Security during this time as her
biological father was disabled she was
pleased with us she was very parentified
having raised herself she also struggled
with trust self-confidence and safety
awareness we tried to reclaim some of
her childhood with camping summer camp
and dance classes all of these things
came out of our
pocket with some exceptions with grants
for part or all of Camp dance class
class was especially helpful in helping
her reclaim her self-confidence and
self-worth um all these things dance
class be school trip Fields fees
amusement park entry birthday parties
half a minute all um came out of our
pocket they weren't covered by the
stien and then my last child I'd like to
talk about um was nine when he was
placed with us uh we wanted to adopt the
state wanted him in a group home with
his brother he aged out at 18 and was
homeless on the street when he reached
out to us we helped him as as much as we
could uh getting him connected to Job
Corp in New Hampshire Health and Human
Services and other services he happened
to mention to me that social security
was taking him to court for an
overpayment of Social Security benefits
despite him never having received Social
Security with his permission I
investigated come to find out the state
had been getting social security for him
for years money which he never saw I'm
going to now ask if anyone has questions
for this
witness yes representative Raymond thank
you Mr chairman I have a question what
happened with his Social Security
lawsuit so he um the state I called um
Social Security and I called the fiscal
agents at DHHS um and they turned around
and went after the state for the to re
to reclaim the funds instead of the
money that he was owed um so in the end
he did not have to pay for it I
guarantee there are many others that did
though any other
questions seeing
none the test you were allowed to give
was compelling thank you for coming
chair recognizes Megan Dylan from the
New Hampshire legal
assistance can you hear me sorry I
always forget how the button Works um
I'm Megan Dylan I am a non-attorney
Advocate with New Hampshire Legal
Assistant I'm also the public benefits
project co-director for New Hampshire
legal assistance I've spent the bulk of
my career with nhla representing
individuals and children in federal
disability claims um with the Social
Security Agency um and to answer some
specific questions about the rep paye I
wanted to address the specific piece
that we added to the bill about the
suitable rep paye because primarily this
is already embedded in the federal
regulations and I've handed out the
Social Security Palms the program
operations manual guidance that outlines
how the agency is supposed to vet and
assign an appropriate representative
paye for children and foster care and
primarily the Federal Regulations
already outline that the state or the
agency with custodial care is not the
automatic representative paye and should
not be it actually says should not and
not automatic throughout the federal
guidance there should be a thoughtful
process as to who should be the
appropriate representative pay for
children and there's a preferred list of
Representative pay primarily the legal
guardian parent if not stepparent and
beyond that it could be someone who has
a vested interest in this child who
doesn't have custodial care that could
be an older sibling a grandparent there
are many people in these children's
lives just because they're in care
doesn't mean they don't have someone
with a vested interest in this child who
could have been conserving the funds the
entire time we have an example of one of
those children in the room today um that
exactly happens so in these instances
frequently the state was automatically
assigned or applying to be the
representative PE and there was very
little happening related to them
searching out a potential other family
member or person with a vested interest
in this child many of these children
could have had funds conserved the
entire time if that person with the
vested interest had been doing it and to
answer your questions about spending
related to conserved funds or funds for
the beneficiary it is built into the
federal regulations that the mission of
SSI survivors SSDI for children is for
the benefit of the child the child's
interests the child's needs those funds
are to be used towards the interest of a
child many of these children identified
for these very strict benefits and
disability criteria are also identified
for special education and as we know
these children are required to have a
transition plan the transition pen plan
is usually and hopefully reunification
which means they can work with the
agency the Federal agency to ensure that
needs of the child means conserving
those funds for the family to allow that
child to come back to a home that is
complete and current on rent and current
on mortgage because the plan was for the
needs of the child going forward to be
unified with their family that is
something I've seen in my work that's
something that I've seen with children
that I have set up that we have assisted
who have account set up where are
conserving funds and searching for that
appropriate rep pay for those children
wrap it up or did you I did you know
that was exactly 3 minutes woo I grant
you 10,000 international units oh my
goodness well my wife and I do that she
says where's the catalog to redeem them
we don't have it if you find it let me
know any
questions seeing none thank you so much
for coming thank
you next up is Aubrey fredman
oh thank
you save those
thoughts next stop is Marie Nan and
Susan
larabe from
DCF good afternoon Mr chairman good
afternoon members of the committee my
name is Susan larab I'm general counsel
for DCF good afternoon my name is Marie
Nunan I'm the division director for
DCF and in in response to being as brief
as possible we did uh pass out the
actual report that was mentioned uh by
representative walner and again by way
of procedure and by way of of uh
confirming what this is uh last term in
uh the finance committee House Bill 1598
was amended to result in DH HS be given
be given a an appropriation to hire a
public uh consultant to study our
process of conserving and managing funds
to look at our process to dive into what
it means to have a c a child- centered
benefits and management of federal funds
because it's a very very complicated
process anything with the federal
government um especially Social Security
is very complicated and has a lot of
nuances especially at this point in time
that it is at the precipice of what many
states are looking at Arizona was the
Trailblazer two years ago with their
legislation last term U Massachusetts
did similar um uh legislative um acts to
conserve Federal benefits for kiddos
that is also mentioned in the Consulting
um report uh I I do ask that everyone
read that report I think it's a I think
it's a wealth of information especially
in explaining a very very complicated
process thank you and it actually slides
over yeah thank you welcome um thank you
I would also like to add that um
currently um there is cost associated
with uh making changes to the state um
having um access to the child's B
benefits to um be able to pay for costs
for their care um dcyf certainly does
not disagree with wanting kids and
families to have all the benefits um all
the resources available to them as as
certainly as they reunify and certainly
as they um prepare for adulthood we
certainly agree with that um but I do
want to note that it is not included in
dcf's agency budget to be able to absorb
the costs um that you will read about in
in the report so we don't disagree with
wanting kids to have what they need um
but we would have to um have some um
Appropriations attached to be able to um
adopt this change any questions
representative
McMahon thank you Mr chairman is it Miss
Nan yes okay want to make sure I had it
right uh specific to what you just
stated what's the cost of doing nothing
so the cost of doing nothing would mean
that children um the state would
continue to um become relative p in some
instances and and use the cost um use
the child's benefits to reimburse the
state for costs associated with their
care which is what the benefit is is
allotted for um and so if we were to
adopt the changes in here there would be
a loss in Revenue to the state as a
result and we would need to be able to
have the funding to be able to offset
that representative D
Simone thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so if you
have a child in the Foster Care Program
who is not receiving any benefits
whatsoever who reimburses the state
children are often um eligible for 4E
and they still May if they are entitled
to Social Security benefits so 4E may be
a reimbursable service and otherwise um
we have general fund
dollars follow up and in some instances
I should say also Medicaid depending on
the type of
placement thank you so if a child does
not have any other income whether it be
disability or any other
income nobody reimburses the state for
the Foster Care is that
correct so again there if they're fore
eligible there could be fore
reimbursement um and for some types of
care Medicaid is also used to re follow
final followup so if that's the case
with that child then why should a
child's um disability stay with the
state and can't be used for that child
why does what makes that child different
why can't the money be saved for that
child to get a leg up when they age out
of the fosty care system thank you for
that question and we agree again that we
would want kids and families to have all
the resources financially and otherwise
available to them so the soci Security
Administration has certain um criteria
for what um the benefits can be paid for
so relative paye and I realized we heard
testimony to the to the contrary but my
understanding is that relative paye is
for the person or the entity providing
care for the child to be able to pay for
cost of caring for a child there is a
waiver process in place so for example
if a child were to leave a parent's home
um and they were eligible for benefits
and the parent now um loses the benefit
of that they're able to appeal that
decision to the Social Security
Administration to not have the agency
become the rep paye thank you
representative rice thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so what is the cost to the
state when this child gets out of foster
care and is left homeless and then the
cycle continues and you end up with
their children in foster
care So currently we do um we do hold
the um benefits for a child that is
preparing to launch into adulthood for
about 6 months so that they can
accumulate um certain dollars as they
leave so that we can try to support
their care in terms of um costs once a
child leaves the system I I I'm sorry I
don't have the answer that question
thank you and in the report especially
on pages three and four particularly uh
the group the public Consulting Group
who met with us for various interviews
reviewed all of our policies and
procedures and Val at our current system
um they do point out our program
strengths with which already is doing a
lot of child censored conservation and
management of funds especially for that
very vulnerable group that 14 to 17 and
also mentions as another strength the
receptiveness of the legislature here in
New Hampshire to that vulnerable group
uh they point to the legislation last
term that made it possible that 16 and
over kiddos in care can open up their
Bank open up their bank account on their
own can open up their checking account
on their own with certain income
maximums because again SSI says you
cannot have more than $2,000 in income
to make them more financially ready for
adulthood to stop that cycle of leading
into homelessness and the again for
those very vulnerable group and as
director Nunan pointed out that we are
already earmarking those children who
are about to become adults uh get
getting them U hooked up with SSA on
their own so they can become their own
rep PE come 18 years old
followup kind of a follow-up Mr chairman
kind of followup um jeers like here I go
again um so what would your response be
to the the wonderful woman that fostered
those children and really thank God they
had the money to pay out of pocket for
the needs of that child
how do you justify that money not going
to that child for their
needs because fortunately they could
afford it someone else may not have that
and then that child
suffers thank you for that question and
certainly I empathize with families uh
providing for um Children and Youth with
with disabilities with challenges um and
I I again very sympathetic to that um
the again the the Social Security allows
the benefit to be used for costs
associated with the care and the needs
for the child and so as the state agency
when we're providing for for the care
and for those for those children um that
is why we're currently taking that those
dollars and reinvesting it in the
children's
care representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman I'm trying to
think because she pretty much took most
of my question um so is there a reason
in a case and I want to go back to the
foster mom that we heard from because
that's our like on the ground firsthand
experience um can you explain why she
would not have been able to get those
funds for um the child that obviously
had some needs that um that could have
helped with because I'm confused as to
why that didn't happen I'm not familiar
with her case specifically but if I
understood her testimony it may have
been the child was deemed eligible later
um and so one might think that she could
have been eligible as a younger child um
one of the things that we appreciate in
this report is some of the
recommendations made to the state of New
Hampshire um one of which is that we
could increase the screening and we
agree with that um that is a step that
we can certainly take that doesn't add
additional costs it it certainly we we
could absorb that um as a dcyf agency
and be able to ensure that when kids
come into care we have dcyf nurses
thanks to the legislature and kids that
come into care also get medical
screening and behavioral health
screening and we could use that to
determine potential eligibility
sorry thank you so just to follow up
with this um putting this
into um practice would then help
situations could very well help
situations like hers where she was
trying for the when the child was much
younger to be able to get that okay
thank
you representative Raymond uh thank you
Mr chairman so my question is just that
um the report didn't make its way all
the way around the table so is it in
electronic format or some other way that
those of us who don't have it could get
a
copy because I'd very much like to
reference it yes we can get that thank
you five more yeah representative George
six more
thank you chairman um I is I I don't
know because is someone asking me one
day uh they was taking three
children um but they didn't want to give
them any benefit but they need to
support the children by their own and
they told me how they can do the that
because the the two parents cannot um be
with the kids make it a question please
yeah question was why they cannot give
them the benefit why they cannot even
support why they can have a benefit like
a to get a or food stamp or something
they said they cannot give it to them
why if it if already this is because I
think so this U 6611 I can support that
so once a child come in comes into out
of Home Care the family is no longer
providing for the care and support of
the child and and that is why the state
becomes representative P um again I
mentioned it's my understanding families
could um provide um ask for an exception
to that as Canen a relative um if they
were receiving pay um at at at the time
the child came into care but at at that
time the state is then PR preparing or
providing the care for the child and so
is is then responsible uh to to accept
those
dollars saying no further questions
thank you so much thank
you chair recognizes Dawson
Hayes for three
minutes hello Mr chairman and committee
um I want to thank you all for allowing
me to speak today I I'll try to you know
make it quick um my name name is Dawson
Hayes I was a part of dcf's foster care
system from August of 2021 until I was
adopted last year um for three years DCF
pocketed my Social Security payments
keeping a total of
$116,000 that was intended for me this
is a common practice for foster kids
whose parents are disabled or deceased
this is unfair because DCF already
receives Government funding for the care
they arranged for foster kids like me I
wonder why only the foster kids who are
entitled to social security or venerates
benefits are essentially forced uh to
pay for their own foster
care I was told by my case worker that
the money was kept to pay for the care
and Services I received I have to say I
certainly did not receive an extra
$166,000 worth of care and services
foster kids need every Advantage they
can get and this obviously includes the
Social Security or venerous benefits
that are intended for them according to
the report that was recently completed a
lot of foster kids have these payments
taken from them by DCF this practice
must stop fewer than half of foster kids
even graduate high school and only 3%
graduate from a 4-year College in fact
22% of foster youth experience
homelessness within their first year out
of care considering these facts it seems
incredible that DCF keeps any of the
money that would actually go a long way
towards helping the foster kids I think
the money should be saved and put into a
high yield savings account for the
children to have when they get out of
foster care for a jump start to help
with the cost of Transportation food Etc
my own sister aged out of foster care
luckily for her My adoptive parents
bought her a brand new car so she could
get a job and not struggle with
Transportation but without this she
would have had no way to get a job and
keep it and earn money this is the
reality for most foster kids who age out
they have no resources and no way to
keep a roof over their heads that's why
so many end up home homeless the thing
is this money can mean the difference
between being able to support yourself
or ending up on welfare and food stamps
for survival if you want foster kids to
grow up and be independent and
self-sufficient they should be given
every bit of help to start with their
adult lives $16,000 might not seem like
a lot of money but to a foster kid I
promise you it truly
is again thank you for allowing me to
speak today if anyone has any questions
I'm happy to answer them to the best of
my ability any questions representa of
Greg thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for being here would you believe I don't
have as much of a question is thank you
for articulating that so thoughtfully
and so well and really speaking to your
cause um truly you you're a remarkable
man so thank you for being I appreciate
it thank you and the next time you come
I owe you 24 seconds thank you Mr
chairman thank
you chair recognizes Cassandra Sanchez
from the office of the child advocate
who wants to speak for 2 minutes she
said it let's
see with Lisa masio handing out things
yes um and I may even be able to be
briefer now because that was so
beautifully said wasn't it great yes it
was wonderful um so for the record my
name is Cassandra Sanchez I am the child
advocate for the State of New Hampshire
um and I am here in support of House
Bill
661 um I agree with the testimony before
me in support of this bill um and I do
just want to add a little a little bit
of um my experience in working in
Massachusetts with children in the
system and their social security funds
um when I worked for the state of
Massachusetts which I left in
2021 um we at that time already had been
conserving funds for kids and Care um as
already explained it could meet it could
go up to the max of $2,000 at any given
time and then as social workers we were
responsible for spending down their
funds on something that they needed um I
can give you a couple of examples of
items that we would get for children um
often times particularly for for U
Middle School or teenagers um laptops so
they could do homework at home um that
they could do up job applications um and
this is something that would carry them
through typically through college as
well the laptop was purchased early on
and in good quality they can preserve
that and then use that in college or in
their future career um also children are
children they want to have nice things
like their peers have and so we would
have kids that wanted really nice
Sneakers but we could not expect foster
parents to fo that bill because they
were already paying so much to be able
to provide the day-to-day care and so to
be able to gift a child a pair of Nike
sneakers that they want around their
birthday time um because they they have
the funds they are available to them it
was giving them a sense of normaly and
that sense of normaly has a true impact
on their long-term outcomes because now
they don't feel different than they're
not marginalized and they do feel like
they can amount to something someday um
other things as mentioned already um
intensive therapies that are not covered
by insurance
um devices for children who have
disabilities U we recently had a call to
our office about a kiddo in care who had
a communication device that was broken
um while they were at their facility the
facility did respond appropriately and
immediately reached out to insurance but
that left that child without a
communication device for almost a month
um and then they were having visitation
with family and during that time they
could not communicate with their family
um which created more outbursts and
difficulties in their visitation and IDE
that child should have had that device
immediately if those funds were
available that could have been purchased
by the division and they could have that
even as a backup device in the future um
so there's so much that can be done with
these funds and for that reason we are
in support of this Bill thank you any
questions for
OCA seeing none thanks for coming again
thank you very much chair recognizes
Emily Lawrence from Waypoint
good afternoon chairman and members of
the committee my name is Emily Lawrence
and I'm the advocacy director with
Waypoint Waypoint is a nonprofit
organization that works with children um
that are involved with with the division
for Youth and families in a couple of
different ways one is that we provide
inhome services supports and services
for court that are court ordered when a
um when a child comes into the system
and then also when a child exits the
system we often provide services through
our homeless Youth and young adult
programs and so what I'm passing out to
you today is actually testimony that was
written by our program director for the
homeless youth young uh youth and young
adult programs she was not able to be
here today but we wanted to share um
some of her experiences with these young
adults who age out of care often into
homelessness at right when they age out
or may experience homelessness several
years
after um I think there are several
examples that we put in the letter so I
don't want to belabor that but just to
say that there are countless stories
that she has seen of young people coming
in um who have as I said aged out of
care we cannot confirm whether they
would have been eligible for SSI or not
but even if we took a fraction of those
it would still be a significant number
of kids who could have benefited from
that money to help them with things like
even basic urgent Necessities clothes
food shelter a phone um and then more
longterm as well for Education um
helping them to find a job and just to
connect with other people in their
community transportation is another need
that we see frequently so we are in
strong support of House Bill
661 and we hope that the committee will
pass the bill I happy to take any
questions thank you very
much gosh I got to think of something
that's thank you so much sure thank you
next up is Robert
tangue and you sir have 3 minutes and 17
seconds because you were so on the good
clock last time remember I told you you
had 17 seconds in the bank so 317 for
you
sir Mr chair I'd uh appreciate some
interest on that inflation is very
high
um my name is Robert tangue um I don't
know too much about this bill but I was
listening to the testimony I'm kind of
getting warmed up for uh what's going to
be happening in the future um
today I'm the author of uh New Hampshire
Oliver Twist and if you guys have uh
read or heard of Oliver Twist it's a
story about an orphan who is abused by
everybody who was around him uh with
officials um what I the gentleman's uh
young gentleman's testimony earlier was
very relevant uh to what's going on I
mean I'm looking at a US debt clock and
I don't know if the committee knows that
every every single
citizen in this room everybody has
75.6 th000 in debt so that young
gentleman was born with $76,000 in debt
and then when you look at a family of
three that owns a house with half the
equity and the average house price is
$500,000 a person who has a family is
actually in the positive I didn't get
that luckily I had a
and I'm very thankful for that um so
what we have with this bill it seems
like they're
intercepting the state is intercepting
funds and taking it away from the people
who actually deserve it we're born with
equal access
to all of the state's resources and the
country's
resources
and I think that that's something that's
very important for a
young disadvantaged youth to be able
to have available or a foster parent to
have available so that they can go spend
it at cannaby Lake and give the child
something that and then it goes into our
economy so it's really just redirecting
the funds to the
state which is I believe the state's
largest employer is the state and then
uh taking it away from disadvantaged
youths uh I will ask for some Le lency
on my time and and I don't think that
there are any questions that need to be
uh asked I will note that I watched
every point5 seconds the national debt
go up
$116,000 thank
you put 47 seconds in Mr Tang's Bank
thank you chair
recognizes Emma
savini from new futures
good afternoon chairman Pearson and
honorable members of the committee for
the record my name is Emma savini I am
the children's Behavioral Health policy
coordinator at new Futures new Futures
is a nonprofit nonpartisan organization
that solves problems through policy
change and we are here in strong support
for Senate Bill 661 today we are here in
strong support of this bill because it
en ensures that Foster youth have access
to concrete supports
either during their time in foster care
or after which is a proven way to reduce
the impact of adverse childhood
experiences and give them the best
opportunities to succeed later in life
countless Studies have shown the impact
that toxic stress can have not just on a
a child's mental health but actually in
the physical brain structure they have
when kids are exposed to traumatic
experiences which many many in the
foster care system have been um these
adverse childhood experiences can have
have really long-term devastating Health
consequences higher rates of heart
disease diabetes um depression
suicidality uh anxiety the list goes on
and on providing concrete supports is a
proven way to mitigate the impact of
Aces um Aces have uh can be mitigated by
protective factors and then well-being
can be improved by promoting promotive
factors concrete supports are both so
not only does this uh stipended of money
that the children are have access to
during foster care and afterwards have
um a protective ability on the child to
make sure that their uh Aces scores do
not impact their health it actually
promotes their well-being Studies have
shown that when um kids and families
have access to finances they have higher
rates of long-term stable employment
they have long-term um Better Health
outcomes and mental health
outcomes um so for all of those reasons
and all of the reasons that other folks
have so eloquently put uh new Futures
urges this committee ought to pass on
this bill happy to take any questions
any questions for miss
savini seeing none thank you and my love
to Chloe thank you you're
welcome seeing there's no more pink
cards on this I will close the hearing
on House Bill
661 and we will have to exec this uh the
first first session in
March because it's an early Bill and
then on to
finance thank you for coming we're going
to take about a two-minute rest here um
while some folks are leaving others are
finding
seats
everybody
okay
e e
to the chair
I
e e
because of the number of the pink cards
I just want to let everybody other than
the prime sponsor know you are going to
get three minutes otherwise the door
shut of the building at 5: and you will
be shut out you will have wasted a day
off of work and you will not have
testified and that's not a threat that's
just how the Clock Works so I've got a
mitt full of pink cards here and some of
you realistically ask for three minutes
except for one who did 2 minutes and 30
seconds I love you thank you so that if
you have written testimony that you're
going to read you may want to take out
adverbs and things like that chair
recognizes oops excuse me
open the uh hearing Committee hearing on
House Bill
and representative Bernardi I'm going to
give you 10
minutes thank you Mr chair I know
sureair I can get through all this in 10
minutes because this is a huge huge
responsibility thank you chairman thank
you committee uh I'm here to introduce
HB 652 which is to abolish the family
court and I start off with the rationale
of why this is necessary So Family Court
was established in two in uh 2005 so
it's been in existence for 20 years and
yet it is antithetical to two
constitutional Provisions Article 15 and
article 20 uh requiring that uh uh any
litigant be given the opportunity of
court in equity as well as two statute
at requirements RSA 490 D3 and
4914 in in in point the fact people get
shunted to uh the family court through
RSA 4911 and
two so the family court has uh generally
been uhj not generally been adjudicated
by judges uh the presiding officer is is
often a marital Master now called a
referee as such they are not
constitutional officers RSA 490 d8
defines the qualifications of a marital
master that they have professional
experience in family law of matters
knowledge of Family Matters personal
maturity personal qualities of patience
and
understanding fine okay so in uh 2007
this this this I'm I'm trying to shorten
this up here the the the uh the Senate
uh uh brought a question to the Supreme
Court uh and it was defined that marital
Masters are not constitutional judicial
officers they are further not subject to
the New Hampshire judicial Judicial Code
of Conduct like other constitutional
judicial officers they're generally not
attorneys therefore not therefore the
bar association has no jurisdiction over
them ultimately uh in most cases there
is no official mechanis me ISM to to
address their
accountability in hearings Witnesses are
often not sworn in hence there's no
pursuit of perjury Family Division is
known in the public as the Liar's Court
the facade of being a judge is
maintained by placing the court fac the
court in a court facility and requiring
by law that the the presiding officers
wear official black robes
as
mentioned marital Masters uh orders are
only recommendations to make them legal
they have to be countersigned by a
constitutionally appointed and qualified
judge RSA 490 D9 all recommendations of
marital Masters shall be signed by a
judge the judge signing such
recommendations so certifi that he or
she has read the recommendations and
agrees that a meral master has applied
the correct legal standard to the facts
determined by the merital master in 2007
judge uh administrative judge of the
family court judge Kelly proposed an
amendment uh in the Senate and to repeal
that requirement that they that these
orders be counter signed by a judge
because quote unquote it is virtually
impossible for a judge to spend the time
they have uh going through the file to
uh to really get an understanding of the
case to measure the case against the
facts that they have found uh that were
found by the master it is virtually
impossible I think without sitting in
the courtroom and seeing the witnesses
and judging their credibility and
listening to all the facts of the case
for a judge to second guess someone who
has just done all that is not really a
review that occurs right now under the
law it is a signature it is a
co-signature to the Master's
report the 13 February hearing results
the bill was not adopted yet all these
inadequacies and deficiencies of the
system still
remain one would expect the rules of of
the circuit Circuit Court Family
Division should be consistent with the
rules of the other circuit courts in law
and Equity however rule 1.2 states that
the Family Division May wave the
application of any rule except where
prohibited by law rule 2.2 indicates New
Hampshire Rules of Evidence do not do
not
apply in case after case you have heard
litigants claim their ability to present
evidence or gain Discovery has been
seriously and severely hampered because
rule point one 1.25 States the court in
its discretion May limit or expand the
scope of Discovery in any case as
Justice requires the ability to present
evidence and make Discovery is critical
to establishing one's case and is
repeatedly being denied by this
system litigants are not informed of
these
deficiencies there is no informed
consent that they're waving their
constitutional right to a trial in
equity and that they're submitting to a
quasi judicial review and findings of
facts by individuals who are not
constitutional officers and therefore
have no right to judicial conduct review
their only appeal is to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court where findings
of facts are not reviewable because the
app the the Supreme Court's only looking
at the law as applied to the facts that
have been found by that marital
Master this lack uh this this past year
re recent session the legislature
repealed the judicial conduct commission
which was established in
2010 to rectify this problem because
there was one clause in that law that
was found to be constitutionally
deficient so now there is no opportunity
to rectify this problem so these
deficiencies indite the family court
system as it is currently as it
currently exists it's
basically that worm written being eaten
by an apple being eaten by the worm
except there are way too many
worms how do you know the harm will
continue well you're sitting in a
committee that's dealing with those
harms Time After Time day after day and
there were established two special
committies to also deal with these
problems I sponsored hr14 two years ago
creating one of those committees the
thought was the victims would come
before you and and make their case and
then you could bring the family court
judges in to hear what their rationale
was you could do that you are as
qualified to be a family court judge as
they are I read you their qualifications
early on you meet all those
qualifications you could have made those
judgments instead the work is focused on
training Staffing and other issues not
dealing with the fundamental
deficiencies of the system as a
whole more Band-Aids on the
corpse I believe the actual review of
cases is necessary to determine whether
the family court judge should be removed
an actual review should would
demonstrate a pattern of violations or
abuses you're not going to catch any
hidden envelopes or any other nefarious
activities but if you listened to the
cases and reviewed case after case in
those special committees you would have
found patterns patterns that have come
before you already alienation of
affection claims reunification therapy
with
abusers evidence of covert surveillance
I gave a one this is new I gave the
chairman a document here where there's a
little screenshot indicates a someone
has tapped into someone's private Zoom
meeting that turns out to be linked to a
family court judge there are more of
those kinds of activities they only come
up quickly it's hard to get a screenshot
we're lucky to get one
here we have a system that fails to prit
testimony as I indicated by the rules
you have a failure of bcss to follow
Supreme Court decisions you have had
testimony early on where a a a uh victim
came before you and explained she went
to the new hampsh Supreme Court five
times I'm going to give you two more
minutes to wrap it up
well then I cannot go through begin to
go through this and fully explain the
problem of this I mean Mr chairman the
family court system is broken it is
fundamentally
broken you know that members of this
committee know that you hear these cases
day we are prepared to speak for
ourselves and not have you speak for us
I I'm speaking for what I have observed
that is your opinion it is my opinion
yes indeed it is so I will turn then to
the the uh provision I provided which
the the greater provision which is the
uh explanation of what the recommended
changes are
fundamentally uh you you see that I have
basically sent most of the activities of
the family court back to the Superior
Court that's where they were before
2005 if you look at the first page of
this
document towards the bottom you see
jurisdiction
d.2 you see articles uh sub articles 1
and two those are the articles that I
have offered a mediation program to deal
with articles 3 through 10 go back to
the superior court or in some cases to
the Probate Court where they originally
where why a why a mediation
service and and what kind of mediation
service am I proposing well the
mediation has been used by multiple
courts uh in other states already and
that's where I drew this this uh idea
from is less costly than the the current
system um furthermore um I have placed
controls here where the mediation system
is to be be conducted in accordance with
guidance by the AC Academy of uh Family
Mediation uh uh
professionals um they have standards on
training they have standards on
qualification they have standards uh on
on quality assurance and uh would
therefore assure that mediators in the
program are not putting their thumb on
the
scale I I I can't
make it shorter than
that any questions for the prime sponsor
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and um thank you are there any
states currently that do not have family
court I don't have a full uh
understanding of what system is in every
state that's it's every state is
different so they they may have family
courts that are
that are that are part of their superior
court system uh you know as a division
or a separate entities some uh go
directly to mediation as a matter of law
it's it's you know it varies state to
state so follow up follow up are there
any states that use mediation in the
cases of child and abuse and neglect
cases I don't believe so and that's why
I have if you look at the Articles 3
through 10 the neglect cases the abuse
cases those types of cases uh I I've
said they need to go to Superior Court
you need to be in a court of equity for
that thank you I appreciate
it you had said earlier that I was as
qualified as a family court judge and in
my fantasy life I am but I don't have a
JD they do no they don't they do not
need to have a JD it's not a requirement
most of them do family court judge
that they are not required to have a JD
they're not required to be a member of
the bar
association I read I read you the
requirements um get to my notes I can
give you the citation of
the qualifications are found in RSA 490
d8 490 okay look at 490 d8
thank you so there's no one on this
committee that I believe that does not
have the capability of standing as a
family court judge and therefore you
have the full ability to review and
evaluate the harms that you have heard
and then
ask the judges that made that decision
to justify those if they make sense you
have the you have the common sense
ability to understand that decision does
doesn't make any sense why are you
putting this child back in the hands of
an
abuser I have another question uh for
you uh what would be the benefit of
creating a second mediation office since
we already have one the reason I created
a second mediation office rather than
take the current one is uh because the
current the qualifications to be a
mediator are are are not well understood
by me in the current system I gave you
this handout it let a particular person
who is a mediator and a family court
judge and on his advertisement he
advertised that he handles cases with
high net worth Personnel that is not
someone who is a neutral party that is
someone who's going to put their thumb
on the scale in the favor of selected
individuals and I don't want that Med
mediation and arbitration group to have
anything to do with Family Mediation
that's why I separated it now that's not
to say that you couldn't adopt the
standards that I have put into the
legislation from the
afpm uh FMP excuse me uh and require all
mediators to meet those requirements and
that would potentially take that
individual and individuals like that out
of circulation but that's the reason
given
the statements that the special
committee heard that some family court
judges then rotate over to probate for a
while and they're not especially trained
in family
law even though uh one of the small
victories the special committee got was
further training for our judges now in
Family Court what makes you think think
that kicking things up to Superior Court
which I see in here numbers of times
would find a Judiciary any more
qualified or trained in Family Court
matters because in Superior Court one
has to follow the laws of equity meaning
you have to have full due process rights
in the Family Court as I went through
those are gone there are none available
to
you I think the Rules of Evidence are
discretionary They're Not absent it's
not just the Rules of Evidence it's it's
far beyond the Rules of Evidence I when
the quote unquote family court judge can
decide what evidence they're going to
listen to and someone wants to present
well here's the circumstance of my case
yet they're not heard that opportunity
is
foreclosed and there's no reason that
they can be given an opportunity to make
their case because the family court
judge says Ah it's not important that's
not going to happen in a court of
equity anyone anyone has full
opportunity to present their
case all issues will be
heard okay looking to see if there's any
other questions representative
Greg yes I wonder um and I in
understanding in depth how Family Court
works and how they have to go about
certain things and also the
complications that come in how do you
suppose that putting it mediation so
that people can have all of their
information put out there when we have
people come in here and they have stacks
of stuff first stack is like that how do
you suppose that they handled the
workload in this state and what do you
think the um backlog would be to uh put
this all in this situation or give it to
the Superior Court well first off I I
recommended that the uh that the phase
out be through two years and I'm going
further recommend to this this committee
that if you realize that this is this
kind of approach is a necessary approach
that you may start just like the family
court did in one or two counties trial
the system work any bugs out that may
exist and then expand it to to the rest
of the State uh that is not in here but
the two-year issue is in here um
it the number of cases of of divorce and
child custody what not are are are not
going to change I I don't think we're
changing our our climate and our culture
so the same number of cases appearing in
Family Court are going to actually
appear either in mediation or a choice
to go to Superior Court and that's
that's the choice that I give anyone
coming before the court saying I'm
seeking a divorce you get to choose you
get to choose a court in equity or you
can go to
mediation if at present 80% of cases in
Family Court are
prosay how will these people equally be
able to go to Superior Court where if
all the rules are in place who knows all
of those rules or if one person does is
not the other proos at a distinct
disadvantage so in when you appear a
pray in front of the Superior Court the
uh the judge is to give leeway to the
understanding of the rules of evidence
and the rules of procedure
leeway in making appropriate motions
they're going to have to guide them
through that and that's what they do now
if you if you come to court on a real
estate transaction and you're a prosay
person you you you are not going to be
held to the same requirements that a uh
a professional attorney is I'm
encouraged that since one seems to be
negative towards the leeway the judges
and family court have you would give
that leeway to Superior Court judges too
because in in Superior Court or the
Supreme Court this these are
these are courts where full
constitutional rights are granted full
du process must be
held it Family Court doesn't that's I
started off this and I know it is
damning and it's maddening that this is
this is the truth but the truth is there
is lack total lack of due process in
Family Court it is it is a a court where
that family court judge operates
essentially at whim you are totally
subject to that person's discretion on
how they want to deal with you and your
rights
are you may be granted some you may not
it's you know pays your nickel and takes
your chance it's it's not an acceptable
way of doing business it's
unconstitutional it's unlawful and I
hate saying that I absolutely hate
saying that and I'm humbled by the fact
of all the people that I've met and
dealt with and raised these issues
before me I I can't possibly represent
the pain that they felt going through
this process but the family court system
you know they I it's my understanding
and again I'm operating on hearsay now
my understanding was set up because
people show up in Superior Court and
there's a trial of criminals and the
next case is a divorce case so the
divorce people are sitting in the uh
docket next to the to the criminal
docket people and the judges well we we
don't we want to separate these people
out we want a nice convenient place for
these domestic issues to be
resolved and in so doing they dumb down
all the rules and they dumb down the
Constitution and as a consequence you're
you're left with people that you know
I'm not saying that every family court
judge is bad but you have many of them
that are that have unique crazy
crotchets everything goes to the woman
everything goes to the man everything
you know there's there's alienation
everywhere there it's there's all kinds
of
crazy things that are happening and
worst of all and I didn't get to raise
this this is all superintended by uh
title 4D monies and title
4D has been corrupted to pay for this
system and that's not not what it was
designed for it was not designed to
force it was designed for cases where a
parent abandoned a family member so the
deadbeat dad for those of you who
remember back in the in the uh Clinton
era right guy skips town you know lived
in Iowa he goes to Kentucky and and is
not paying a child support that's what
title for D was designed for well the
way title for a d now forces the family
court to operate or or it not forces
incentivizes the family court to operate
is is a place where it induces the
single family uh single Parenthood
situation and then that feeds on case
after case after case where the parent
who has been forced to not have access
to their children keeps knocking at the
door and keeps the case open
protracted cases that's the problem and
that's a pattern that you would discover
if you asked these people to give their
testimony and you collected it time
after time you would see that pattern is
there I have the testimony from amaly
Olsen a New Hampshire legislator who now
you're testifying again I'd asked you a
question thank you for that well I'm
answering question you know you're good
at that that's really I'm taking a note
here brother
any other questions for the
representative
George thank you chairman um thank you
very much for for to stand for families
and uh I believe what you say for
everything myself I'm really witness um
for this one because uh to call Li C
that really that would make me really
feel but uh like you said is in
Constitution
constitutional um
Cod how we can change that to become
Constitution because to come
constitutional because is a to then to
bullish you can change I know you I
change make it you can change that to
make it that to look
good so so your proposal is to make the
family court a constitutional Court yes
well we'd have to pass laws that say
that all these uh Provisions that they
uh have have abandoned in the in the
rules are are
illegal uh and uh um we have to say the
family court shall comply with uh with
the full rules of equity because divorce
circumstances are uh are cases
inequity representative
marel thank you Mr chairman um sir
earlier you mentioned you saw problems
with Discovery did I hear that right yes
that PE people have that have that
problem if they they're not allowed to
present the case they're not allowed to
to they ask the judge well we want to
see you know this evidence from the
opposing party and it never shows up
it's never
discussed yeah Discovery problem that's
a due process issue okay um followup yes
if I may thank you okay so are you aware
of how do you know what interrogatories
are yes I do okay do you what's I'm
sorry yeah follow sorry about that um do
you know what the limit of the number of
interrogatories you're allowed to ask in
Family Division are I I do not know I
don't know the rules to that degree okay
um do you know what
followup I'm would it surprise you to
find out you're allowed to ask 50
questions and have virtually unlimited
requests for document production
wouldn't surprise me you're allowed to
ask but I'm what I'm also would is
surprise you that uh that none of those
get looked at or maybe three out of the
50 get looked at and 47 get dismissed as
inappropriate or or not worthy of
discussion well do you know what this
followup do you know what the standards
for Discovery are
sir I enlighten me please well in other
words sir would it you're allowed to ask
for virtually anything that's relevant
to the case that relates to a claim or a
defense of a party as long as it's not
privileged and are you aware that some
of the limitations that involved is when
Discovery becomes crosses the line from
oppressive and harassment to asking
questions that are more focused and
relevant and by way of one more question
one more okay are you aware also that in
the Family Division uh you're also
allowed to file motions to compel and
motions to strike interrogatories if for
some reason they bound on something
that's inappropriate for the case I I
I'm sure all that's true I'm also sure
that one rule 1.25 says the judge can
site that's nice and move on okay and um
do you know how many may I one
more I'm going to give you
sixpack okay thanks okay out of
curiosity how many qu how many
interrogatory questions are you allowed
to ask in Superior Court sir I I I I I
do not know I don't practice in front of
the suprior court okay thanks no further
questions seeing no further questions
thank you for your testimony I I I would
just recommend uh cat uh Hinrich as
someone who's got some interesting
data chair recognizes representative
Susan
Dy co-sponsor of the
bill and we're now into our three
minutes segment role except for one
person at the end who will be a
rebuttal thank you for allowing me to
give some testimony today my name is
Susan Dy and I'm from St straford
District 3 which is New Durham I didn't
think I would be here today but when I
ran for office I had in one I had four
people immediately contact me over the
last couple of months about what's
happening with their children and I'm
scared to death for
them their stories are are extremely
alarming and very similar children are
being placed in or allowed unsupervised
visits with abuse of parents these
children often return with bruises
Burns scrapes and even worse and many of
these people are going to testify this
today one of the most troubling aspects
that I've I hear is a recurring theme of
punitive and biased treatment to the
reporting
parents these parents are
motivated and have a desire to protect
their
children frequently they become targets
of skepticism and hostility from biased
magistrates and um guardian and lims
the negative response not only deters
other parents from coming forward but
emboldens the
abuser those who interpret the systems
failure to
act makes them think that their behavior
is
okay most importantly this situation
puts the children let me say that again
the Children at Risk forcing them to
endure endure a cycle of abuse that has
lifelong effects and those lifelong
effects keep coming back and keep coming
back and keep coming back and you know
what that means that means money people
are making money off of these children
and off of these parents we must reform
our form Court family court system to
help these parents and their children
regain their lives no longer should
cases drag on for 2 to 3 years allowing
abuse to continue and draining parents
saving on attorney fees and court fees
if they can afford them at all and many
can't they can't defend
themselves this bill proposes closing
the administrative Court as has been
told and transitioning these cases to
judges who follow the law and that's
important we not going to go over all
the benefits because you'll hear that
coming fourth you've got 30 seconds okay
and I I just pray that you all listen to
these people and put yourself in their
place and think to yourself do I want my
child to go through this and do I want
to go through this thank you thank
you the chair recognizes
Matt here we go I'm going to try it
saurin D
schier how' they do oh and I was so
wanting to know how to pronounce
that got a big stack of pink cards and
you're all going to get 3 minutes
each I would just remind you you may not
speak about a judge by
name however angry you are however right
you think you are that is not allowed
anybody who does that your microphone
will be immediately turned off and
you'll be asked to
leave chair recognizes Stephanie
Turon Mr chairman can I ask a procedural
question yeah are there any rules about
protecting the identity of children in
testimony yeah and you cannot make thank
you and don't make mention children's
names either thank
you got to turn your mic
on um thank you somebody asked a
question earlier about what states have
abolished the family court actually I
can send this to you guys's email New
York actually has effective January 1 of
this year I'll send that to you all
later um I stand before you today to
give testimony in full support of House
Bill 652 to abolish the family court in
New Hampshire with deep conviction and a
heavy heart my experience with the
family court has been traumatic to say
the least and has at every turn violated
my rights as a parent my right to
religious freedom and my fundamental
right to protect my child from harm I'm
here to tell you that the current family
court system has completely failed my
child my family in the public in every
conceivable way my son will turn four
years in June of this year and we have
been involved in the family court system
since October 2021 when my son was 4
months old um where I am the respondent
in that that case or in the case since
day when I've been fighting for my son's
safety and well-being to be put first
for my right to raise him in accordance
with my beliefs however the court has
continuously dismissed my concerns
especially regarding the abuse my son
has endured at the hands of his father
my son's father was arrested out of our
apartment for domestic violence against
both my son and me when my son was just
3 months old he was later ConEd victed
by a jury of domestic violence against
both my son and me he was later
convicted of criminally stalking me this
is not just an accusation it is a matter
of public record to make matters worse
my son's father is an admitted opioid
addict who has admittedly been in active
addiction during points of my son's
short life the family Court's response
give my son's father 4 and a half days a
week of parenting time and give his
protective Parent Me 2 and 1/2 days a
week yep you heard that right no there
is quite literally nothing that the
court has against me I don't have a drug
problem never have don't have any
criminal history of of any kind um
sounds shocking but it's actually common
in the in the family court because it's
clearly not a real Court they don't care
um my um after these incidents of
domestic violence my son's father snuck
into the to my son's school and also
became violent and threatening to the
director he then chose to have a 2-hour
standoff with police which resulted in
him being criminally trp pass from the
school altogether months later my son's
father threatened a nurse at the
pediatrician and was criminally
trespassed from there as well which also
led to the practice dropping my son as a
patient altogether despite the fact that
my son and I are adjudicated victims of
domestic violence the family court still
requires per their court orders that my
son's father and I share equal
decision-making responsibility including
but not limited to scheduling all
pediatrition or specialist doctor's
visits in according with each of our
schedules so that we both have the
opportunity to attend this does not
protect me or my son as adjudicated
victims of domestic violence and clearly
disregards my safety um despite my son's
father's convictions in an adjudicated
finding by
DCF um
involving
um lots of abuse a black several black
eyes busted lips and near
broken thank you for your testimony we
do have to keep it there's a room full
of people
very day the chair recognizes Anthony
Kenny please come on
up we have a room full of people and
three minutes is fair to the other
people good morning members of the
committee yes
sir for the record I'm very skeptical
about being here today as my family case
could you be closer to the mic thank you
for the record I am very skeptical about
being here today as my family case is
still ongoing I believe because I've
already faced retaliation through the
court that my being here today might
affect the outcome of this case I'm here
today in support of HB
652 I've often heard said in discussion
in this committee and as other
committees about the family court only
parents that are on the losing side come
forward to testify that's not the case
here today my co-parent and I share
equal custody I'm not on the losing side
in May of 2020 my co-parent went to the
family division with intent to take my
parental rights away the clerk informed
her that she needed a lawyer for such
action my co-parent was then referred to
an attorney who was not only a partner
at the same law firm as a presiding
judge and he was a managed partner her
boss but also had a deep personal
professional ties with the judge the
family his family and the clerk court
um the court clerk sorry before our
initial temporary hearing while my
co-parent was withholding visitation i s
an expar order uh which was denied
during the hearing after my co-parent
attorney remarked why are we here the
experte was denied the judge responded
Yes we had it denied at the temporary
hearing following the attorney's
recommendations the court stripped me of
my decision-making rights which were
granted by God and protected by both the
New Hampshire Constitution and the
constitution of the USA granting my
co-parent so Authority while also
severely restricting my visitation
communication and contact with my son a
g was appointed who was also a longtime
friend with the judge what began as a
lowc conflict case has now stretched
nearly 5 years escalating to a high
conflict battle fueled by the court and
its actors the conflicts were created
within the court upon discovering the
relationship between the judge and the
attorney I requested the judge's recusal
and was met with retaliation after four
years of battling this Court's
manufactured conflict I finally regained
equal rights and responsibility due to
exposure and involvement with judicial
conduct committee the judge was
ultimately forced to admit his bias that
he had not been fair and impartial and
he had to recuse himself violations of
the Judicial Code of Conduct as well as
his own oath of office during this time
my son endured repeated abuse at his
mother's house strangulations and
attempted drowning and other violent
incidents at the hands of his older
siblings his mother resorted to physical
punishment including hitting him with
wooden utensils and forcing him to
ingest Dawn dish soap as one of multiple
punishments that morning before sending
him to school 15 seconds Sir five
separate dcyf investigations initiated
by medical professionals and law
enforcement documented these dangers yet
despite presenting clear evidence of my
expart was denied the court refused to
put any evidence on the
record do you have any questions for the
witness um I have one um I think I heard
you mention a judge was disciplined by
the judicial conduct commission that's
good to know I mean not that they had to
be but it's good to know that it can
be committee okay
sorry thank you sir chair recognizes
Randall Collier
got to push the button Bingo good
afternoon chair committee um I'm for
this bill to abolish Family Court uh
title 42 is a non-positive law title
which means that there isn't actually
real evidence that goes on in family
Court um when you look up New Hampshire
executive branch um agencies and you go
down to the letter f f it says uh family
mediators chapter 328 that's exactly
what they are family mediators um
they're not supposed to do
constitutional issues they're supposed
to be independent third parties uh if
you look into administrative law uh
Circuit Court Family Division is all
three branches of government in one
where the executive branch runs a show
using judicial branch
documents US Supreme Court Justice gors
said that American uh administrative law
judges are not judges and these are not
courts um the reason why it needs to be
abolished because there was uh talk
about Rules of Evidence uh and motions I
filed uh three motions for Discovery two
for show cause along with 500 other
motions uh all denied um so when it said
Rules of Evidence don't apply but it's a
preponderance of the evidence uh this is
direct um washing machine uh child abuse
from the court uh you can't have
preponderance of the evidence if Rules
of Evidence don't apply it's an
oxymoronic statement
um yeah let's abolish family court so uh
we don't hurt any more innocent
kids uh I did uh two parenting appeals
to Supreme Court a motion uh a r of sear
Supreme Court both all three denied uh
two district courts and the US court of
appeals all denied 12 years protective
voter no evidence
um this is the definition of child abuse
through all branches of government um
and it's in the American judis Prudence
so if anybody has a question you can
read it it's all three branches of
government in one so it's not very cool
to military veterans we don't we don't
take highly to treason and child
abuse thank you chair recognizes Aubrey
fredman who now gets to testify because
I got the hearing
right Mr chairman committee members I
speak uh Aubrey Friedman I live in
Bridgewater I speak in support of this
bill uh the family court is a rogue
division of the government and it's
clearly I mean there could be an
isolated case here of U abuse or what
but there's tons it's a it carries a
history of abuse and tyranny and so uh
I don't think it can be reformed to be
honest and I uh they don't clearly don't
follow due process and also this
business of not swearing in isn't that a
red flag right there not swearing in
even when you do testimony for your the
online bills or whatever you got to
you're like test you know it's a you're
kind of like perjury thing not swearing
in in a court so that's a red flag right
it can't be reformed I like the idea of
the mediation court or mediation office
Family Mediation office try to work
things out voluntarily and maybe that
can uh bring some of the volume down I
mean naturally it's going to be
adversarial with family divorce and you
know problems like that but um doing it
voluntarily can maybe bring the volume
down and then if they can't work it out
then it goes to Superior Court and they
have to follow due process in the
Constitution and also I just want to
mention that the taxpayers are evidently
going to be on the hook for a lot of
this abuse and Corruption that has
happened and so if we go to something A
system that works better uh like the
mediation and the superior court that
will uh I think we're going to have the
taxpayers are going to have to pay a ton
of money but uh maybe in the future in
some of this abuse and the and trying to
rectify it through claims and so forth
so those are the reasons that I support
the Bill thank you thank you well spoken
uh we have a
mediator thing now where people can go
and try to work it out and it only goes
to court when that doesn't work or they
don't want to do
it well something isn't working right
now because otherwise why are we having
all these um te horror stories
basically well I don't know about that
but I do know there's a lot of cases now
and that's because the divorce rate's
about
50% but um we do have a mediator program
going on before they get to Family Court
are people advised of this you know you
can do this first I'm
wondering why we have somebody who
actually knows other than me I don't
know so would you believe that my
daughter is going through a divorce and
for a year has been involved in
mediation and it's still ongoing so I
don't I'm not sure how this bill is
going to help speed up any processes
because she has been with mediation
which is very costly to her and when he
doesn't want to agree to something then
it becomes more costly to her so I'm not
quite sure how this and she sees no end
in sight right they just schedule
another mediation appointment four
months down the road so I don't see how
this this by having everyone go through
mediation would um speed up the process
well it would be voluntary so I think
that's the key thing if they choose to
do it and maybe I don't know how many
would or advise maybe it's a better idea
but it could help follow up Mr chair
follow up so this was ordered by the
court she didn't voluntarily go that
this mediation was ordered by the court
for her uh under this bill it is it is
voluntary so if they don't agree to it
then it goes right to the superior court
and they have to follow due process I
think that that's the difference here
and if they have to follow everything
exactly as it's listen I've read The
Rules of Evidence book five times and if
they have to follow various
things I've read it five times and I'm
not sure I could do it so I'm just
wondering what does this do in in
Superior Court you have to hire EXP Ive
lawyer um I'm just trying to get my hand
around this here well following due
process I think giving everybody a CH a
chance to present it uh so each side
feels like they got a fair shot I think
that's the difference here and and
following the Constitution okay any
other
questions thank you thank you Katrina
Heinrich
oh and she has handouts we like
handouts if there's only one of each
they go to the clerk of the committee
for filing thank you you didn't I like
how you kept that going right along
thank you thank you this is
we have had a history of people
forgetting to pass
things he miss Hinrich while they're
passing this around welcome to Children
and Family Law committee thank you thank
you for having me again welcome I'm
Katrina Heinrich and
um I was asked by the bill sponsor to
provide some data for you guys to look
at which is on its way
around and some of it is critical in the
way
that those of us that's been working on
this for quite a long time have been
using a methodology that's very similar
to the doj has to have three three
verifiable things has to be detectable
has to be verifiable and it has to be
quantifiable so for application if
there's a pattern there's a pattern and
then you guys can go ahead and educate
yourself on the little blib they have
for the rest of
it the next
sheet is actually a graph I put together
for you and this is case profile
samplings this is I can't even tell you
how many cases we went through on this
this um to form these patterns to
discover what exactly is going on and
comparing it to what they're saying
which is often and you guys know this
it's very emotional for them um but we
need to put it into a data we needed to
find a way to do that so we had to find
words that made sense and this is the
chart that you've got if you'll notice
at the end of the chart there's a little
key that says um Na equals does not
apply kind of common one
but it was much easier on this chart to
put in the three things that didn't
apply than fill in the whole chart with
x's and what this is at the top is those
a through G are actual
cases those are the years of the cases
so it's a huge sampling it's different
courts another sampling and yet we found
the same patterns being reported in
these cases all always resulting in the
child being abused a parent being abused
or both parents even being abused um so
this chart really gives you kind of
insight into the layers of it the theme
of this is that the family court was
unsustainable in about 2007 they started
realizing they did not have enough
families in need to support under title
4 so there was um an upswing shall we
say in looking for cases in higher
income families and I believe that
representative Bernardi handed you one
of those people who is a judge
and targeting started there now with
that said I did comparison with the
state of Minnesota Minnesota found the
exact same upswing at the exact same
time and the swing has never stopped
it's continued so 20 seconds yep this
chart gives you that and the last page
because we keep talking a lot about how
these cases
are shall we say artificially created
and they have a lot of high
conflict when we hear about we hear
about high conflict as in there's
something wrong but in this particular
case this is from Cohen and winter and
they were looking at
HB HB um 185 for the parental rights
yeah and they respond to it in their own
blog and you'll look at the bottom the
bottom yellow you guys we're going to
take a look at that do you will you
accept any
questions qu any questions
questions thank you your
testimony excuse me Mr chairman could I
just request I don't know what's going
on but there's just never enough copies
to reach
me well sometimes they don't reach me
either um
give it to
me it dis does a disservice to the
person testifying if there are not
enough copies for the people in the room
so it doesn't help their case basically
that's their problem to
solve yeah um Mr chairman I think um
maybe not everyone is aware that we need
one copy for the file so maybe that's
why you're getting
short okay the chair recognizes Cullen
for 3
minutes not seeing a Drew
cullins chair recognizes
Frank he took a
shortcut he was going over that way yes
sir yeah got to push the button got it
there we go
good hi I'm Drew Cullen I support 652 I
been a litigant in family law for nearly
8 years and have 30% parenting time I
pay around $800 a month I underscore
that I have no criminal history I'm a
veteran business owner homeowner elected
Town official UNH Alum father in some a
normal guy uh no different from many of
the L litigants and people you hear
today my case has hundreds of filings to
include two Supreme Court appeals one of
which dealt with the eth circuit in Keen
stealing my parental rights on
vaccinations and basic religious rights
to exempt my 8-year-old from being
abused with the covid-19 jab and thus
overriding laws that you yourselves
wrote It's case 2022 0445 go read it you
can read my entire case uh in the trial
court as well I'll even give you
permission to see the sealed stuff if we
have a
Judicial uh oversight
uh the New Hampshire Supreme Court
upheld this blatant abuse of my basic
rights and my daughter's health and
safety making law from the bench and
denying basic rights is an anathema to
our way of life we petition our
grievances to this body year after year
decade after decade so that this body
will reign in the lawlessness in the
Judiciary which as history has shown is
the most corrupt branch in the New
Hampshire government and the few bills
you manage to pass are watered down and
Toothless our civil rights are being
violated in family law our kids are
being kid napped and abuse our money
unjustly stolen we are denied juries and
the presumption of innocence and uh
equality before the law and that is why
family law must be abolished this
legislature must end the human
trafficking which occurs every day in
family law and restore Liberty to the
free peoples of New Hampshire if you
have any questions I'm happy to
answer well stated thank
you Kang L chair recognizes
good afternoon sir thank you for
recognizing me for three minutes uh to
begin I'd like to say that the word
court is used improperly these so-called
family courts are not courts that's TW
total 42 USC 666 they are
administrative expedited administrative
and judicial procedure that is an
article to uh procedure it is not a
court of law it is for the adjudication
of a of a public entitlement either of
child support from the state or of
foster care uh managed by the state it
has nothing to do with private rights
that is why they are not courts of law
under article 3 next I want to say that
the persons who are involved in those
courts so-called courts are incentivized
by quote in incentive payments computed
as a percentage of child support
collections that's 45 fcr
30412 that is a that is essentially an
illegal act conducted by an officer
because they are being false they're
they're being corruptly influenced uh to
give one side of the family more
parenting time in order to obtain a
greater child support um ruling which
will benefit the state's
agency um but and and the persons who
are doing this you you're right they're
not necessarily JDS but I'll tell you
something else they are not in fact
acting on in their behalf as judicial
officers because that would be a
violation of separation of of uh of
powers Doctrine they're not acting as
judicial officers um and even if they
are a Judicial officer what they are
acting under is a interdepartmental
service agreement between them and the
agency of the state responsible for
collecting the money under F title 4D or
or title uh four which brings me to uh
the other uh point is that chapter sub
chapter 4 is entitled Grant to States
for Aid and services to needy families
with children and for child welfare
services meaning that it should not be
applied to normal people who have
otherwise functional families and who
are otherwise financially
solvent it is this misapplication of the
law that is that that is the most
concerning to me because the law is
actually written quite well it allows
the state to take care of the most needy
and most vulnerable members of society
15 seconds however it has been corrupted
to be applied to everyone which means
that that um it is used to to profit
those who are in charge of of of
administrating those
things thank you for your testimony
could you print that
out I mean I don't think I will send you
an email give me about 24 hours sure
enough I mean there's some good stuff in
there I want to check out it's the truth
well let's maybe if it's truth that's
good stuff and and the people are are
not told this so they feel like the
quote unquote judge is doing them wrong
but in fact would you take some
questions CU your time is up I'm afraid
any questions nope thank you I'm looking
forward to
that chair recognizes JP NAD
and you know what I did when I testified
before a committee the other day I
didn't put the button on either it's on
well the red light will tell you you
just hit something and if it goes red
you did it there it is okay good
afternoon thank you for letting me speak
I'm I'm speaking to you as an attorney
with 50 years of experience both as a
trial and the marital matters
I I'm speaking to you as an attorney
with 50 years of experience I open been
a trial attorney in marital matters uh
in the early 70s I served as a marital
Master which had had similar Powers as
your your family court judges now where
they just hear things then they issue an
order or make a recommendation I've
served as a marital mediator and and as
a
g take your time
sir
but I'm speak I'm speaking to you as a
grandfather
I'm sorry give me one minute sure enough
sir would you like to go back and we can
call you up again I I always have
this I'll get over
it the I support this bill
wholeheartedly um it really is Family
Division should be abolished and there
should be this family uh office of
family mediation with professional
mediators psychiatrist or psychologists
I know mediation doesn't work you know
as somewhat here but you really need
professionals the Family Division for
example I've had experience in this over
the past four years um they'll have 30
minute hearings on office of proof with
multiple motions at the same time that
gives each side 15 minutes to make a
presentation to the court there's no
checks or balances because you don't
know what the other side may say to
counteract it
you can have clients or people making
with a narcissistic personality wanting
absolute control over the children will
do anything to get it and say anything
to get it if a judge um does not like
you in the first instance to some extent
or has some type of attitude towards you
you can't change it and the problem a
big problem in the family division
is
the if if you're on the wrong side for
any reason attitude or whatever the
judge will pontificate in its orders and
I I mean pontificate so that if you
wanted to challenge it if you want to go
further on whether the Supreme Court or
whatever in instances they they they
justified in there um there
is um I'm trying
to one there's discussion for example of
of interrogatories in Discovery in the
50s
50 uh interrogative submit well if a
judge says fav one side and that side
submitted
156 in subp Parts the judge said well
that doesn't count the subp parts if
this rule 125 required disclosures if
the other side wants to play games with
Discovery they'll say he didn't provide
this or she didn't provide this one item
and the judge will say you can't do to
Discovery you can't take depositions
until you comply with 125 but that's a
single individual making a judgment call
and as I say to you if there's if
there's an attitude against you it
really protracts one gentleman said
protracted divorces more creates more
conflict you got about 20 seconds Sir
I'm I'm I'm done I owe you no I'm done
okay thank you any questions for
councel seeing none thank you sir thank
you chair recognizes Chris B
berno do I have it
right the name
burs oh like you wrote somebody else
like you
wrote uh thank you um I come here today
to give you a bit of a perspective from
someone who has practiced law in New
Hampshire a little closer to the mic sir
for the ancient of years for 23 three
years I've been practicing law in New
Hampshire so I give you the perspective
of an attorney's view here as you
probably know there are three levels in
the court system here Supreme Court
being the highest intermediate is your
appell at County courts the superior
court and your entry level is your
circuit court comprised of the probate
family court and District division now
for reasons I still haven't figured out
after 23 years of practice the technical
Rules of Evidence don't apply in the
cases I still don't get it I get the
theory behind it is you don't want
children placed on
technicalities but the reality is there
is somebody a gatekeeper the judge who's
going to tell you what you can let in
and what you cannot let in and under the
current system it has to be material and
relevant and you get a ton of evidence
based on emotion and you're getting
decisions based on emotion because
nobody is
explaining you can't let what the
exhibits in that have no probative value
and that should be explained to them and
it's
not in addition to the lack of
evidential rules There is almost no
appellant oversight here in certain
cases there was a time where you could
take an appeal a denovo appeal from the
family court to Superior Court
specifically abuse and neglect cases
but some years ago that Avenue was
eliminated now your vast majority almost
exclusively appeals from the Family
Division go to the Supreme Court
straight to the Supreme Court and the
odds of the Supreme Court taking your
run-of-the-mill disagreement in a
marital case is almost
non-existent unless there's a new
statute that needs to be
interpreted and everybody needs that
view you from the Supreme Court it's
almost always you're going to get a a
form letter from the Superior Court
that's the Supreme Court rather that
says the best Court in the position to
determine the credibility of witnesses
and evaluate evidence is trial court so
we're not going to disturb their
findings so compare that to the federal
scheme which essentially says all of
your federal rights come in different
shapes and sizes they're not all equally
important your fundamental rights are
your most important parenting rights are
in that group so they're subject to the
St strictest
scrutiny and the current system I I see
she's showing you the watch this oh half
about hour feel strike that half a
minute so the US Supreme Court has
determined in the case of tville that
parents are deemed to be fit parents
unless the the state has proven
otherwise and what you currently have in
abuse and neglect cases coming forward
is you can have a non- accused parent
who wants to get their child back but
under the current statutory scheme they
actually have to file a request and the
court will schedule a parental Fitness
hearing for that parent who's non
Accused by the state to try to prove to
the family judge that they are adequate
to take their child back when they're
not facing any charges
any questions
for counil just a couple of statements
um I am working with and I'm going to
blank it out but it's I think it's the
New Hampshire Bar Association is working
with me to produce an intro book for
people who are going prosay and I've
been talking with their executive
director to see what can we put in it
because I there are materials but I'm
not quite sure many people are knowing
about that much less getting them but
that will speak to the issue of why did
they do that and what do I do next and
if this then what doesn't solve every
problem but it will solve maybe a few
and you might also be interested to know
that I've been given the authority to
make a subcommittee out of this
committee we'll probably stand it up um
April or May to pick up the good work
that was started in the special
committee on the Family Division of
Circuit Court yeah we were putting
Band-Aids and you know what it did some
good job did good job doing good work I
think we're going to do some more so
thank you for that and uh seeing nothing
more appreciate
counselor chair recognizes Brooke low
farmer
hello this is quite intimidating I'll be
honest um when I was asked to come um by
the representative I said I was very
apprehensive to come and share my story
as my another father mentioned my case
is currently ongoing and has been
ongoing for three
years um so I guess I'll just tell you
part of my story because it it echoes a
lot that's already been said so I'll try
and be quick for you chairman um two and
a half minutes so letter a rule all
right okay my case is out of the 9th
District uh Family Division um the judge
has presided over my family case since
the beginning in September of 2021 the
judge's rulings over this case
demonstrate clear biased against women
veterans and law
enforcement this is my personal
experience um in one proceeding the
judge would cut me off and not even let
me speak and another um it was my uh
parenting plan that was being discussed
I was employed as a police dispatcher
after extensive background checks
polygraph my ex-boyfriend the father of
my child and his Council ultimately got
me fired from my position due to slander
subpoenas to my employer the police
department sending private investigators
to harass me while I was at work into my
home the judge remarked in his ruling
that is an unfit employment for a mother
to work for a police
department the judge has allowed the
father of my child to weaponize the
family court system to keep me in
constant litigation with no means to
afford an
attorney the father's attorney
herself defending the father who is a
domestic violence abuser while she sits
on the board for Bridges a domestic
violence
shelter all of our Exchange just take
place at a PD a police department and I
wear a body camera that cost me
$7,000 with a lawyer to get that one
change done in three years that is the
only thing I've gotten in my favor
$7,000 throughout all of these
proceedings the father has testified
falsely and nothing's ever done about it
the judge has misapprehended abundance
of information presented throughout the
these proceedings including falsely
stating I testified under oath that the
child would be adversely impacted by
spending more time with me the mother I
have audio recordings of all of my
hearings nothing remotely close was said
in family court if you can afford an
excellent attorney it seems allow
perjury as with the case of my recent
trial the father of my child made
completely false statements that I
easily disapproved by my testimony and
evidence I presented the judge never
addressed that either
in his ruling he said the petitioner
often times seemed unable to answer
questions or confused you have 20
seconds but seemed
truthful that's the TW you done no I
have so much more I'll give you 20
seconds you're on a roll thank you I
guess why I'm here is his last ruling
this judge like we heard for so many
others is made a biased decision that
being in law enforcement for a woman
woman and a mother was not okay he
essentially ruled that the father would
get the
child his last ruling removed a
three-year-old little girl from her
mother her three siblings to go live
with her single alcoholic father whom
had not spent any significant time with
her until she was 2 and a half years old
will you take any
questions okay thank you thank you you
came here kind of trembling you did a
great job you really
did boss be like this
yeah us are we intimidating no I I don't
think so anybody when I sit
there thank you chair recognizes Alice
jodano
you get three
minutes no no we control that this isn't
Congress push my little button here then
and here you
go my name is Alice jordano and I am
testifying in support of House Bill 652
I am a national news reporter and in my
30-year career I have never come across
anything so corrupt as the new Hamp
family courts it is a system that is not
riddled with honest mistakes but rather
comprised of a bant people with a
deliberate fetish for making Lawless
decisions impoverishing parents
willfully traumatizing children and
putting them in danger all to carry out
personal agendas and line the pockets of
a cottage industry comprised of greedy
club members and Gatekeepers I should
know I am one of its victims I lost
everything to this Mafia like ring and I
and while my daughter now College Bound
was and remains an overachiever she is
scarred for life by The Reckless actions
of this nefarious click instead of
seeing to it that a troubled man gets
the counseling he needs in order to ever
be safe around his daughter this Anarchy
used him as a pawn in a battle it
deliberately insights to keep the
profits flowing to its cronies the
Court's Twisted crusade to Gaslight a
parent and engaged them in an ultimate
battle for their children's life is like
a family caught version of Hunger Games
in my case it tried to force me forced
me to hand my daughter over to a man a
self-admitted transient who never spent
so much as a day as his daughter's
parent didn't even know how to spell her
name in court pleadings and called her
dead weight a man who told a
Massachusetts parole board that he
understood where his brother was coming
from when he explained he executed his
girlfriend as she lay sleeping with the
new newborn baby because quote he didn't
want the responsibility of a
family a deadbeat father Abed by the New
Hampshire family court in his open vow
to never spend a dime to support his
daughter when my daughter was five I
asked him to show some interest in her
so he showed up at her school grabbed
her and smashed her fa face against the
sidewalk and then left the country I had
over 37 sworn witness statements and
other evidence detailing this Terror but
the court in its chronic quest to keep
evidence off the Record rejected at
least five separate motions requesting
something so basic as an evidentiary
hearing and New Hampshire family court
judge wrote I thought about granting M
jono's request but then decided why
bother since I already knew what I would
decide another judge wrote openly wrote
he wasn't interested in evidence and the
Court's so-called child advocate told an
attorney abuse doesn't matter only what
the court wants but the senseless and
indefensible actions didn't stop there
and a move many have ascribed as
shocking the conscience this judge one
of the judges since I can't mention them
issued a secret kidnapping order of my
12-year-old daughter writing the father
shall obtain the
without the mother's knowledge this
unrestrained directive was to award an
adolescent girl to the same man who told
the court that he sometimes pays cash to
sleep in a basement in Washington DC and
spends the rest of his time in Singapore
and Bangkok sex trafficking epicenters
of this world thank you for your
testimony do you have written
testimony you are finished ma'am others
manag to abide by the rules you are
hurting your cause by behaving this
way chair recognizes Frank
kland good afternoon chair and committee
members I support this bill today 50% of
the US marriages end divorce with that
being said divorce is more than a $60
billion
industry when it comes to divorce money
does the talking most people cannot
afford a divorce as a whole the family
court system is nothing more than a
business plan it's a money-making
business the average cost of a marriage
license in the US costs about $30 to
$70 on what a state couple is residing
in the cost of divorce is an average of
about 27k to 57k and that's yearly
depending on how much money a person
does or does not have if a divorce case
goes on for 4 years that can cost over
$108,000 if a marriage license is so
cheap why does a divorce cost so much in
any civil courtroom you have the right
to an attorney and a jury decides a
verdict however in family courtroom the
judge is the dominant one decision maker
the constitution in the United States
does not apply in Family Court a person
does not have the right to an attorney
and there is no jury when it comes to
divorce with children involved the best
interest for the child is equality
between both parents that means 50/50
the court system is not a friendly
environment and does not work with
equality seeing it with my own eyes
attorneys encourage their clients to be
aggressive as possible often encouraging
their client to make accused accusations
of course if someone is getting accused
of something that they didn't do they're
going to fight against it more fighting
means more time in court more money
spent and if a person does not fight
they can lose everything and that
includes his or her children the federal
government provides incentives to States
for Family Court Serv Services through
title
4-D of the Social Security Act these
incentives include reimbursement the
federal government reimburses States for
66% of eligible child support
establishment modification and
enforcement costs incentive payments
states receive incentive payments based
on their cost Effectiveness and
collections matching grants states
receive federal matching grants for
child support enforcement how it works
States submit a Fally approved state
plan for the federal government States
designate a child supp agency prepared
the state plan and entered into
agreement with the federal government
states receive federal reimbursement for
eligible costs states receive incentive
payments based on their cost
Effectiveness in collections and yes the
courts do discriminate against veterans
I thank you for your time and thank you
sir for being concise and brief and on
point Thank You chair recognizes Dana
alre
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee uh my name is Dana alre uh I
think you've heard a lot of the problems
with the court from other people I would
just add to that uh February 4th on
House Bill 350 you also heard a problem
wherein the chief J former Chief judge
of the administrator Court uh who cannot
be named uh committed uh perjury in his
August 26 2022 deposition uh with intent
to submit
falsified uh sign off un falsified
transcripts uh for
appeal that being said I'd sum up what I
heard earlier is that uh our magistrates
and officers of government are not
accountable to the people at all times
and uh rather than that uh we have this
family court that constitute the private
interest uh or ement of any one
man uh family or class of men uh public
Liberty is manifestly
endangered thankfully we have this bill
as an effectual means of redress please
pass this
bill the trouble though is wealthy men
are sometimes difficult to convince as
we've heard for 2,000 years
when the rich man was unkind to
Lazarus you've heard
many Pharisees teachers of the law
public officials come before you telling
you what a good job they're doing trying
to justify themselves I I didn't hear
them say they fast twice a week but same
difference and you've
heard a grandfather here
beg for
mercy you've heard so many families
here and maybe we didn't do
everything
right in our family
life but we're begging you for
Mercy ask
yourselves who is
Justified in this situation
please pass this Bill thank you and
thank you you come here quite often and
are eloquent sir thank you thank
you chair recognizes uh Drew
Cullen chair recognizes Teresa
bastos ah
almost oh there is okay yeah I mean
you've been writing it a lot longer than
I've reading it so yeah yeah I think you
got so my yeah my name is theres Bast as
thank you for the time today um I've
have gone through divorce I can
sympathize with what your daughter has
gone through I'm also a mom who adopted
my two sons out of dcyf custody in total
I have about 10 cases in the basement um
probably about seven years in Family
Court the one thing I want everyone to
hear today is that it is a racket it is
not in the best interest of the children
it is not in the best interest of the
families right now for every collected
for child support the state gets
$512 back from the federal government
it's money driven it's not
constitutional if you think about it
what is the most corporal punishment
thing you could do to an individual you
could throw them in jail for life you
could put them life to prison but I
would say taking someone's child is
right up there and we're doing that
without
constitutional what our forefathers put
in place we don't have a jury we have a
judge who will decide whatever the heck
he wants to do and I know I only have
three minutes I'm going to go as quick
as I can the most crazy most recent was
my 10-year-old who I have permanent
guardianship over his grandfather came
out of left field he had been told by
DCF he was not allowed to see this child
because of evidence of sexual assault on
this child he came out of leftfield and
asked for grandfather visitation rights
very clearly Define the RSA what he's
allowed to do went in front of the judge
the judge decided to give him a
parenting plan that I was to give him
his medical records his school records
an update every week as to all of his
activities and unsupervised visits
including Christmas Day for8 hours this
child had not seen this man in 6
years the other judges that came after
and that's the one thing every time you
go to a hearing it's a different judge
so you have to start over and you're
revictimized you're wearing people out
hundreds of thousands of dollars in law
losing your home when I should be there
for those boys and helping them as a mom
as a Mimi no I'm pulled out of work to
go to court every time I turn around
that's not efficient these cases should
be over and done with within a month but
they drag on for years and hundreds of
thousands of dollars at the detriment of
those parents being able to be healthy
for those children but this judge he he
ordered a parenting plan the judge I
said is this a grandfather's visitation
or is this a parenting plan because I'm
not going to be the one to set a
president and if I'm in contempt of
court you can haul me off to jail but
I'm not doing this we're not doing it
and Christmas was coming I prayed I
fasted and you know what happened out of
nowhere this 10-year-old decided to
confide in a school teacher with how he
had been sexually assaulted by this
grandfather we knew something had
happened but he wasn't willing to talk
about it when he was five and six years
old that teacher mandere reporter
reported it investigation happened the
police talked to the grandfather he
dropped all of the requests through the
family court that was our Saving Grace
to protect that
child that judge was legislating from
the bench and we had no recourse none
thank you for your testimony that's a
compelling story you have does anybody
have any questions for the
witness representative thank
youly can you explain the $1 child
support to $5 back sure so as you have
to go so say you have a deadbeat dad or
you have someone who's not they they're
taking it from the paychecks it's going
through D DHS to get to the mom or get
to whoever's in you know been ordered
the child support for every dollar that
goes through that system there's a total
of $512 in incentives that come from the
federal government back to the state so
there's there's a money driven to drag
this out to not have 50/50
custody I don't distrust that for a
minute I can get it I'd like thank you
like to have it in my hand yeah thank
you yep it's it's corrupting the whole
situation thank you for your testimony
chair recognizes robertt Tang who has 3
minutes and 47
seconds you're really building it up
there my
friend the power of compound
interest uh I will
make allow someone else to make my
introduction
polic6 on the line located at two
Pillsbury Street 300 in conquer we can
hear this the bar association so what
we're hearing is a police call from the
bar association where I went to go get
help um and they called the police on me
and it's documented but an individual
that they've identified that they don't
want to do business with but he was an
individual they don't want to do
business with the pro litigate that's
all accurate okay what's the
business the business is the New
Hampshire Bar Association New Hampshire
Bar Association and who is this
person uh his name isbert tangu
t g a y That's me
okay and they're gonna sit they're freid
me okay so uh do you want to trespass
him well we don't know that he's left
the building we just want to make
sure okay so they don't know what
building you're not sure if he's left
the building and then what we don't know
that he's left the building and we want
to make sure it's safe for our people
safe for our people okay can you
elaborate on why it wouldn't be safe
why wouldn't it be safe he had repeated
contacts with our office and his name
and picture posted on bulletin board of
people his name and picture are posted
on a bulletin
board Robert tangue haven't seen my kid
in over two years no arrests nothing
some of you people have uh not even not
even uh I guess except for the State
trying to arrest me um and I've been
before this General Court uh many times
and also did the same tactic that the
domestic violence Coalition so I I I
oppose this bill and I ask that I get a
couple extra minutes if not I do request
that you guys do ask me questions
because I'm a wealth of knowledge I I've
read the family courts I've read all the
statutes including 546a colon 5 which
requires the judge to shall consider
assets and determining child support
the system that we have in New Hampshire
this bill won't pass we need to
repeal 173b which is domestic violence
which is being used to
weaponize at the benefit of lawyers and
Federal grant money the courts
fictitious domestic violence petitions I
have also video that I uh that I can
sent to you for the latest court hearing
CU I record all the court hearings with
permission uh where the
judge after after having the defendant
laugh uh said that the police
tell people to go to court to get a
restraining order so when you look at
the hierarchy
of uh evidence probable cause is what's
required for a police officer to apply
for a
warrant uh preponderance of the evidence
Which is higher standard is required for
a domestic violence petition so what we
have is really a backet of lawyers uh
lawyers who are making money and
advocating laws including the domestic
violence Coalition which has spent over
$10,000 last year in advocating for laws
and it's all in uh public record
so I know you guys can't rehear
my case and we really have a problem
with the Supreme Court so we're going to
the people who are not able to help
judges right lies that's why we need a
jury we could just simply repeal this or
uh repeal the family courts and then it
would go back to the way it was before
we wouldn't have to do anything but I
think we also need to repeal if we
really want to get the change and people
because these people haven't been heard
I haven't been heard that's the problem
and Mr tangu I think we're going to cut
you off here because of time but are you
said you would ask answer a couple
questions I hope briefly does anybody
have a couple of questions on
suggestions I have to make the bill
better might help you I will give you
one more minute because you're one of my
frequent flyers thank you sir okay so we
need a jury mandatory that that is not a
wable right unless it is told to someone
so when we wave rights or wave
rules uh that needs to be like you
should be able allowed to object to it
so we need a jury uh we need to repeal
173b it's unconstitutional the police
are supposed to make an arrest and then
we also need to repeal uh judicial
sovereign immunity which is
unconstitutional anyways article 8 the
state of New Hampshire you guys need to
read your
constitutions and base laws upon this I
suggest that this committee does go
forward with this bill but examines it
and maybe a subcommittee to finally
resolve this issue in because it's it's
hurting our children it's it's that
simple thank you sir appreciate much any
any
questions no thank you I'll send you all
materials appreciate that God bless
chair represents former state
representative Leah kushman for three
minutes thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee um Leah kushman
where New Hampshire uh New Hampshire
Family
Justice if the legislature creates a
court of law or a court of equity and
then puts it into statute that the court
is not bound by rules of equity or
common law then the court is not a court
of equity or a court of law then what
kind of court is it it's like calling
something a bathtub but it's convex and
made of
paper okay so what kind of court is it
actually I think the ambiguity is part
of the game um I think it's uh Works in
favor of the system of the business
model keeps people confused and not
knowing how to resolve the issues that
they see um if you don't know the rules
you're at a disadvantage and the court
has all the advantage for whatever
outcome it wants if you want to come
back if they want you to come back they
create or um encourage more conflict uh
they'll bring in outside parties um who
also benefit from grant money that's
flowing in from the federal government
from these cases and they create
conditions for your case to be
protracted and here Li the rub when you
are in this court um there is no due
process and if there's no due
process
um then there's you don't have Miranda
rights right there's a preponderance of
the evidence and if you're if there's a
suspicion that someone is ACU is abusing
a child then they've already
incriminated themselves in family court
and there's supposed to be immunity for
things that go on in family court but we
see that that's not applied so it's just
more mixing up of proper process of law
it just poisons the entire well in the
ability to make sure that Justice is is
had um and when they go to a court of
law they can say you know my Miranda
rights are violated and then you can't
stick the charges on this person um so
the question about the mediation about
what the differen is current mediators
are uh private
contractors and this bill proposes a
state budget funded certified family
mediators they're employees of the state
um so then there's no if it's funded
just by the state budget and I say that
for the entire court and the mediation
that's being proposed then there's no
opportunity for federal funds like we've
seen with USA money and um you know
other other Federal programs that are
incentivizing and being abused with
fraud all over the country it's just the
same thing going with the family court
here there's no possibility for that if
you're just running the courts off of a
state budget without Federal incentives
that um you know drive drive people who
are involved in the court to seek
certain outcomes for financial gain so
remove those incentives remove the
ability for judges to use broad judicial
discretion that's ant antithetical to um
American Jurish Prudence anyway if you
read maxims of law judicial discretion
is supposed to be very limited
um right now they already have to hire
expensive lawyers and because cases are
often protracted and because attorneys
um 90% of litigation in New Hampshire is
through Family Court um and because they
know that the judges have broad judicial
discretion the lawyers are often not
willing to go to bat for their clients
because it would be career
suicide you get about 10 seconds they go
through 3 69ine attorneys over the years
what what's happening with Doge right
now they're going to dig into these HHS
programs and they're going to find the
fraud and waste and abuse in the family
court systems across the country it's
being called to be um dissolved Across
the Nation New Hampshire needs to get
out of the way before this windfall hits
thank you will you take
questions we have none thank you for
coming chair recognizes Aaron
kraan good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is Aon krian
I'm the general counsel for the court
system including the Family Division um
representative love I I to to check you
by name I think you made an observation
to me the other day that confidence in
the Family Division was at an all-time
low I'm I'm worried that that isn't true
uh there's actually a long history that
I completely understand in New Hampshire
that we are are are cherish our freedom
and bringing the matters of your
personal life into court is so difficult
um having the court make decisions about
time with your children whether you'll
continue to live in your house whether
you will continue to be married to
someone you maybe don't want to be
divorced from is so difficult I think
it's difficult everywhere but I think
it's it's difficult for granite Staters
um and there has been a long engagement
between the legis legislature and
between the Judiciary and a lot of
different things have been tried um you
know it was an experiment to move from
the Superior Court to a dedicated Family
Division um I do think we sometimes move
in Trends um there was an idea that it
would be better to have marital Masters
because they would be extreme subject
matter Specialists now they're
disfavored there's only one marital
Master left um so we do try different
things um to create more confidence to
create a better experience for
constituents in the family court system
I'm not sure that that has changed the
level of um public discomfort with
bringing these very private and
emotional matters into court um but we
have tried different things and I
appreciate that the legislature is
always looking for those opportunities
to improve if it's a 100 small
improvements if it's one big one um what
can improve people's experiences with
the family court um but I do think there
are some things that are maybe not
correct um the family court is
a duly constituted court with
constitutional officers it is not an
administrative agency the judges are
Judges um under New Hampshire
Constitution part 72a the legislature
can establish courts uh it's it's noted
that the Supreme Court is a
constitutional Court meaning that it is
mentioned and specifically created in
our constitution same of the Superior
Court the circuit court is a
legislatively created court but that
doesn't make it unconstitutional it
simply means the legislature could
change it by legislation without
amending the the Constitution and you
could do that if you wanted to return to
a period that existed in the past and
have Superior Court resume um this work
you could certainly do that you don't
need an amendment to the Constitution I
think you may find that there is a wave
again that there is concern that the
Superior Court judges who are
generalists may not be deep subject
matter experts in family law as most
Circuit Court judges are about 40% of
their time is spent on family cases
there are 20 thousand about cases
brought in the Family Division every
year um thousands of mediations under
the office of mediation and arbitration
including a small amount of paid for
time no she gets unlimited time look
beginning um our mediators are certified
by oplc so they have the family
certification um and this is very it is
very successful a lot of people
appreciate the opportunity to mediate it
is included in the packet they get when
they do a divorce imp parent in case
that they have the option to do
mediation um so we certainly believe in
the court system in doing the best we
can for people and we appreciate how
much the legislature is looking at
anything that can be better
um I don't this will represent a return
to a historical period that you could
study and see if you prefer the results
from that period um but it is up to you
if you want to change things from the
Circuit Court to the superior court and
if you want to have uh two offices of
mediation instead of one um but I'm I'm
happy to answer your questions about
about how the family division
works yeah thank you representative
Raymond we have an expert witness here
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question um so my question
is
about um judicial oversight or audits or
you know visitations and observations in
courtrooms because I'm hearing over and
over again these really heart-rending
stories about people who felt that they
weren't heard weren't understood didn't
understand what was happening or what's
going on with their children and their
families doesn't make sense to them or
judges are acting in a way that doesn't
make sense so is there currently or can
we make a system where there is a like
like I'm thinking about teachers
teachers have the principal or the
assistant principal comes in like five
times a year and observes their
classroom and then gives them coaching
and pointers on how to how to do better
is there a system like that for judges
great question um I think typically if
there is a complaint what you'd have is
that the administrative judge of the
relevant court so if it's Circuit Court
it would be judge Christo maybe her
Deputy judge Kissinger will review that
specific audio and see if there is a
teachable moment a problems that's the
boss essentially of the Circuit Court um
I think one of the things that has
hampered Us in wanting to implement
exactly what you've described which
which is having very experienced retired
judges for example sitting in with the
newer judges is that we have needed to
use a lot of those judges um because we
have been Staffing up to full Staffing
the legislature support in expanding uh
circuit court judgeships has been so
important we are now fully staffed at 49
but a lot of those judges are new um so
there is still a lot of shadowing of
Judges there is still a lot of close
watching and training of those judges
when we can free up some of the more
experienced judges I think that's
exactly what the the Chief Justice wants
to do is have our retired judges and our
very experienced judges sitting in
courtrooms watching the new judges and
giving them direct
feedback followup thank you Mr chairman
so I guess the question is what what
does the judicial branch need from the
legislature or the budget or whatever to
make sure that we're having this kind of
ongoing routine oversight so that
when when these so that these things
don't keep happening to people
I'm not sure it's something that we we
need I think we just need to start being
able to pull these retired judges off of
cases and and be dedicating them to that
um and having the full Staffing of
Judges which the legislature has already
supported is really the biggest piece of
that but I don't think there's a new
resource or a legal enablement that we
need it's just been freeing up
resources representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for being here and answering questions
how um serious so we heard about like a
pattern from some selected cases that
they had but how um serious does the uh
court system take complaints or how do
you handle complaints if there's about a
specific Judge or something like that
there's there's a a dedicated email and
I think I've sent it but I'm happy to
send it which is for Circuit Court
concerns and that takes in everything
that's related to the work of the
Circuit Court there are other patterns
if if you have complaints about other
interactions in the judicial branch and
if it's about staff it will go through
their managers if about Judges it'll go
through the judicial management chain
which is the deputy and and head
administrative judge of the circuit
court so if they see that someone
doesn't seem to it has had some type of
issue they maybe misapplied the law they
might arrange more training they might
do something like that so it's it's
typically through direct contact with
the Circuit Court concerns and they they
see complaints
routinely representative
love representative love sir sit down
representative love hey come on thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question
no go ahead uh reg regarding the
statement about the confidence in the in
the family court system um I don't know
about you I've been sitting here for two
two 2 hours 45 minutes listening to
testimony after testimony and nobody's
spoken too glowingly about the the
family court system I'll stick by my
statement saying it's a complete failure
and I and I think that what I was
meaning to say is that that concern has
been around for a while I don't think
that your concern about the present
state is wrong I think that that's
that's a running issue um that that we
have folks that just are not H that are
not comfortable with the experience that
they had in circuit court that that is a
long running issue um so I'm certainly
not saying that that's not the state
today I think it's been the state for a
while I don't know
how many of the sessions of the special
committee you sat in on I sat in on them
all and I heard from equally angry
people of the same gender I say that to
remove the gender cross issue that the
other one just wanted to stretch the
thing out by more motions by more
motions and the same room full of people
half of them would say they won't let me
bring things up they're rushing to
judgment okay who's right would you
believe that there were numbers of
people who said I want the rule to
change so whatever I bring in as a piece
of evidence will be admitted no you
don't because other people said that
judge allowed my acts to come in and
talk about something that I did wrong 30
years ago and it has no probative value
which is it some of this is I'd hate to
be a family court judge trying to be
fair when you've got equally angry
people people who feel like they have
been dumped on by a I can't give all the
beautiful adjectives of the journalist
system and they mutually exclude each
other I it's very hard for a family
judge but I think it's hard for the
legislature I see that our legislature
was very close to the people and
attempts to be very responsive and and
that is why is always changing there is
there is more revision of the law in the
area of family law than probably any
other area that affects the court system
every year um and you you may hear that
some people are saying I don't like that
the parenting was equal and some people
are saying the parenting must be equal
and the legislature is always trying to
learn from those cases and always trying
to find um a sweet spot but I think you
it is a tremendous Challenge and what
happens is the Law changes a lot in this
area and the judges are always training
and always learning and always trying to
hit that moving Target um but in reality
people are distressed by very different
and very oppositional things they either
want an automatic presumption that
everything is equal or they do not want
to share parenting with the other parent
or have that parenting time
significantly reduced they want to be
able to introduce whatever they want or
they don't want the other side to be
able to introduce certain things it is
very difficult legislatively to
accommodate these concerns in a cohesive
way which is why I think we do go to
Superior Court and then to Family
Division and maybe back to Super again
go to Specialists and then to
generalists and change change the law
it's it's tremendously difficult to
address all the different kinds of
concerns that people raise it was my
experience chairing that special
committee that the
Judiciary really wanted to fix things
and we went as you remember we went for
the relatively easy ones but you know
what if you show up at a family court
and you just don't know what to do and
now somebody's helping you that may be a
minor thing but not to you it is it's a
good thing for for you and I I just
think of um my colleague over here she'd
show up at a hearing to try to convince
some of you people to do something and
you had been listening in on our
sessions and you were already in the
process of doing it you know I I think
you've got the magic touch on
this yeah and I think the Judiciary was
quite open now when we crank up the next
round of this we've heard testimony I'll
be picking five or six people to serve
with me on this subcommittee which will
last two years or a year and a half and
we'll go for some of the things that
we've heard today to see if we can catch
them by the tail maybe we can't but I
don't think we're going to make it worse
I think we have some things that we are
chewing on and I hope we all will do
this and it may scare the Willies out of
some of you and you will not volunteer
you'll run away very fast but I think
some of you I think I'll have a a
subcommittee that can take it the the
next step and I know the Judiciary will
be uh open to that the the people who
work in the judicial branch want to
serve the public they have chosen
careers in public service and to be
honest I don't know anybody wants to
work in family law in the judicial
branch it is tremendously difficult uh
it is the area in which you face the
most abuse from your litigant it is the
area in which you are sued the most it
is the area in which you are threatened
and assaulted the most um in which you
are accused of committing crimes in
which you are routinely reported to the
police for doing your job and not
violating the law um I I really don't
know um when you could be a judge and do
anything if you wanted to you could be
doing the probate cases you could be
doing the criminal cases where you just
do not face this level of abuse um I
really don't know it makes me think of
um being a police officer a few years
ago I thought nothing would shake a
person's calling to be a police officer
and it got to be too much and a lot of
people decided they didn't want to be
police officers anymore no one would
threaten to kill you he became a
firefighter um and now we have a
commission studying how we get people to
be police officers again um you know I
have worried I've seen people quit
because they can't take the level of
vitriol that's developed toward them
they they've taken a job as a clerk
because they want to do something that
matches their kids school schedule they
want to be a public servant they did not
sign up to be threatened every single
day by someone um so that is something
that
I
quiet um so it's a it's a challenging
job it's a challenging job to
do
yeah well good thank
you I do have another card it may be
anticlimactic do you want to testify bu
or
not okay make it brief three
minutes thank
you thank you Betty G from
Salem um I've made several points
they're not in a particular sequence but
as I've listened to really good
testimony all afternoon I thought I
would just try to boil down the the
important points that have come up the
worst punishment is dealt with in Family
Court of all the courts cuz losing your
kids has to be the worst possible
punishment right now we've established
that in Family Court we do not follow
process and although we're getting $5
for every dollar we're not keeping all
that because we're losing judgments in
court because of violating due
process we we don't follow the rules of
evidence but in Family Court current
rules the judge can say we're not doing
an evidentiary hearing at all with no
excuse
that's
legal that's not a good
idea yes we have mediators who work
currently for Family Court they are not
certified by the highest standards they
can hang a shingle but they're not the
kind of certified mediator that is being
proposed in this
bill we know there's a financial
incentive
to maintain the status
quo there a financial incentive for the
budget because of twisting the rules
from uh
Congress Federal money is padding us but
we're not really getting it
fairly but they're not watching either
so we're getting away with
it in New Hampshire one of the things
that makes it really difficult for
people now this isn't family court but
in New Hampshire unlike some states if
you're not can't afford an attorney only
you can defend yourself in court only
you can represent yourself but in some
states they allow you to get assistance
from someone else who may not be an
attorney but there are at least two
people behind me who had to teach
themselves the law because you usually
run out of money most people don't have
the incomes of attorney to pay attorneys
for very many hours so they have to
teach themselves but most people aren't
that good at teaching themselves but
some people thank goodness are and
they've been helping other people but
they can't go to court and represent
them our solution is all the good people
that we have in the current the current
family court system they can still work
in a newly created court it's just that
they have to start following the rules
of of due process it's only fair as
citizens of the United States we are
entitled to courts that follow the
law thank you that was a very wonderful
summation of one side of the argument we
heard today and uh you did sum it up
very nicely I'm glad you put another
pink card in um so your suggestion is
you might recommend through a Court rule
or through legislation that in family
courts a prosay litigant might have the
assistance of a helper of his or her
choosing yes and I understand that in
some cases in some states that is the
law in fact the person who said it to me
and I didn't get to check it out swore
we were the only state that doesn't
allow
it New Hampshire's always first or last
you know that yeah any questions for rep
former representative
gay seeing
none this ends it this concludes the um
hearing on House Bill 652 we will
execute on the first Tuesday of March
now we have additional copies of the
proposed amendment to House Bill 10 the
only difference from what I handed you
last time is it actually has all three
of the amendment writers on the top
where the other one didn't and um the
vice chairman has gotten a pile of these
because we're getting people who are
saying I don't like hb10 because it says
says says or it doesn't say say say and
maybe just maybe the amendment actually
has taken that into account so if you've
got people who are talking about
hb10 you may want to have one or two of
these to photocopy and hand to them um
it's sometimes the case you don't see
the amendment until the exact session I
have decided I want it out there as wide
as it can be so take them if you want
them and we'll make some more thank
you
e
e for